USE ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
JUNE TWENTIETH A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND IT IS ABOUT ONE
FORTY IN THE AFTERNOON.
ARE CALLING FOR MEMBERS THIS IS
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
CLEAN ROOM.
FOR FOUR FOUR SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELCOME TO THE THAT HEARING JUST
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS TO GO
OVER BEFORE WE START.
WE HAVE TWELVE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY WE HAVE ONE ITEM
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT WHICH IS
ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B.. TEN
EIGHTY FOUR BERRYHILL WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM ESTABLISHED.
IN ORDER TO MOVE THROUGH OUR
AGENDA IN A QUICK MANNER ó
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE WILL ALLOW
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
BEYOND THESE LIMITS PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION.
BREVITY IS APPRECIATED.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARS
OF BILLS AND SIGNED AN ORDER --
WE WILL OPERATE RIGHT NOW AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE DON'T.
MOON WE DO FORMS HIS MAKE UP
FIRST --
SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE
[inaudible]
MMHM.
ADWARE CURRY HERE I WORKER HERE
WALDRON BLOOM CABALLERO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL HERE GRAYSON LACKEY
LACKEY HERE REAVIS.
REAVIS HERE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF OUR FIRST
BILL THIS AFTERNOON IS ITEM
NUMBER ONE SP FOUR EIGHTY ONE
NOT SENATOR PAN.
WELCOME SENATOR PAN.
BUT AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS SIDE AND PLEASE PRESENT
YOU SP --
FOUR EIGHTY ONE WHICH IS A
DISTRICT BILL WHICH WILL PROVIDE
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO THE MUCH
NEEDED OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I AT THE SITE OF THE FORMER SAN
JUAN MOTEL AND MOBILE HOME SITE
ON STOCKTON BOULEVARD.
CYNICALLY THE BILL ALLOW THE
COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO'S
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY --
SUCCESSOR AGENCY TO DISPOSE OF
THE PROPERTY FOR BELOW MARKET
VALUE.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
I'M PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE COUNTY
IS SPECIFICALLY REQUIRED TO
DISPOSE OF THE PROPERTY TO THE
CITY SACRAMENTO OR TO THE CITY'S
HOUSING SUCCESSOR ENTITY.
THE SAN JUAN BLAND PARCELS ONE
OF EIGHT PARCELS ARE PURCHASED
AND CLEARED FOR REDEVELOPMENT
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
SITUATED ALONG THE
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR AND
UNDERSERVED AREA OF OUR CITY.
THE PARCELS WERE PRESENT AN
IDEAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
DEVELOPMENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN OUR DISTRICT WHICH IS LEAVE
ME AND WAY SHORT SUPPLY.
I WANTED REDEVELOPMENT ELIMINATE
TWENTY TWELVE TO SEVEN SMALLER
DECENT PROPERTIES WERE
TRANSFERRED TO THE CITY OF
SADNESS HOUSING AUTHORITIES
SUCCESSOR AGENCY HALBERT ST ONE
PARCEL.
WAS TRANSFERRED TO THE COUNTY
SACRAMENTO'S REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY SUCCESSOR AGENCY
THEREFORE SB FORTY ONE ALLOW THE
ST ONE PROPERTY BE TRANSFERRED
FROM THE COUNTY TO THE CITY. FOR
FOR BELOW MARKET VALUE IN ORDER
TO FACILITATE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
MUCH NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THESE
PROPERTIES FORMALLY TARGETED FOR
REDEVELOPING DISPOSED OF
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND TO MAXIMIZE
VALUE HOWEVER EACH MONTH MORE
SECOND A RESIDENTS ARE FORCED
INTO THE STREETS BY RISING
HOUSING COSTS.
AS BEFORE ANYONE ALLOW US NOW TO
ADDRESS THE TECHNICALITIES
ANYWAY TO DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SITE EXPECT
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE I'M
PLEASED TO HAVE TESTIFIED
SUPPORT SECOND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER ERICA.
THANK YOU.
AND SENATOR --
COULDN'T AFTERNOON CHAIR IN
MEMBERS AREA THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO DISTRICTS SIX IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
FORTY ONE OF YOUR COMMITTEE
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY ONE WILL
HELP THE CITY AND THE COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO TO UTILIZE A VERY
BLIGHTED VACANT.
PROPERTY THAT'S RIDDLED WITH
ILLEGAL DUMPING ON STOCKTON
BOULEVARD THAT WAS ONCE THE OLD
SAN JUAN MOTEL.
LIKE MANY CITIES SEGMENT IS
FACING A CHALLENGE AVAILABLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK.
S. TECHNICAL BILL WOULD ALLOW
THE CITY TO ACQUIRE THE BLIGHTED
PROPERTY FROM THE REDEVELOPMENT
SUCCESSOR AGENCY FOR THE
PURPOSES OF CREATING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THE CITY AND THE COUNTY
THROUGHOUT.
THROUGH OUR HOUSING SAID --
SUCCESSOR AGENCY OWNS SMALL IT
JASON LOTS UNFORTUNATELY THIS
PROPERTY OF THE OLD SAN JUAN
HOTEL IS THE LARGEST PARCEL AND
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF
THESE ADJACENT PROPERTIES.
THE REQUIREMENTS IN CURRENT LAW
AFTER THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT HAVE IMPEDED THE
ABILITY TO JOIN THESE PARCELS
TOGETHER AND EXECUTE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT.
THE SAN JUAN MOTEL WAS
ESSENTIALLY THE ONLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR MANY FOLKS --
BEFORE IT WAS A TORN DOWN AND SO
THE PROPERTY SHOULD BE TREATED
AS A HOUSING SUCCESSOR PROPERTY
YOU'RE VOTE WOULD HELP BETTER
UTILIZE THIS PROPERTY FOR MUCH
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND CLEAN THE VACANT BLIGHTED
PROPERTY THAT HAS SAT VACANT FOR
MANY YEARS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS THAT YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE FRANCIS.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
FOOTBRIDGE MANNER NEIGHBORHOOD%
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY.
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
OUR COMMUNITY BORDERS THE
BUSINESS CORRIDOR WHERE THERE
SAN JUAN WILL TELL PARCEL LOT IS.
THIS IS A LOT THAT HAS FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS SINCE IT WAS
THE HOTEL WAS CONDEMNED.
OF BEEN A HUB FOR CRIME DRUGS
PROSTITUTION.
AND TODAY AFTER DRIVING BY IT'S
AN EVER GROWING HOMELESS IN
CABINET AND CABINET [inaudible]
WE RESIDENTS ARE HOPEFUL THAT
THIS LEGISLATION CAN TURN THIS
LOT.
WHICH IS KEY TO OUR ECONOMIC
REVITALIZATION.
IN OUR AREA TO CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WHICH IS SORELY OF NEEDED IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND WOULD ELIMINATE THIS CHRONIC
POLITE BRIGHT.
THE RESIDENTS OF FRUIT WHICH
MATTER.
ARE LARGELY WORKING CLASS PEOPLE.
ETHNICALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
DIVERSE.
SOME LIKE MY FAMILY HAVE BEEN IN
THE COMMUNITY FOR ALMOST SEVENTY
YEARS SUMMER RECENT IMMIGRANTS.
TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
ALL OF US.
A LOOKING TO YOU AND COUNTING ON
YOU.
I TURN THIS OPPORTUNITY THROUGH
THIS LEGISLATION. TO RIGHT THIS
WRONG THAT BEEN GOING ON FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
WHAT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND A HOPE TO BE
BREAKING GROUND ON SOME NEW
HOUSING?
SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE WITH ALL
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TEST BY OUR OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HE THOUGHT ABOUT A HAS THE CHAIR
OF THE US STOCKTON BOULEVARD
PARTNERSHIP.
I GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
SOME MONEY WITH ME GOING OUT AND
THIS IN A DIFFERENT CAPACITY
HERE TODAY AS THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO PLANNING AND DESIGN
COMMISSIONER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THIS ACCORD OUT THE STOCK
TUMBLED OUR PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATHY CRESWELL
PRESIDENT OF THE SACRAMENTO
HOUSING ALLIANCE IN MEMBER OF
THE HEALTHY COMMUNITY BUILDING
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES COALITION
AND WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT.
BARBARA STEINBERG NEIGHBOR FROM
STOCKTON BOULEVARD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
YES MR BROUGHT SOME REMEMBER
FELL.
BECAUSE IS THIS LAND PRIVATELY
OWNED OR IS IT OWNED BY THE CITY
OF STOCKTON RIGHT NOW.
SO I UNDERSTAND IT'S ACTUALLY
THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT --
THAT ONE PIECE IS OWNED BY THE
COUNTY AND THEY CAN'T TRANSFER
IT TO THE CITY AND THE OTHER
SEVEN PARCELS AROUND THAT ARE
OWNED BY THE CITY.
SO WE'VE CREATED THIS TECHNICAL
PROBLEM WHERE YOU CAN'T JOINTLY
DEVELOP THE ENTIRE PIECE OF LAND.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE SAID BILLS
FOR A RESOLVING BECAUSE IT'S
ALLOW THE LAND BE TRANSFERRED
FROM THE COUNTY TO THE CITY UP
LOW MARKET PRICE OKAY AND LAST
QUESTION MADAM CHAIR.
SOME.
SO NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE COUNTY
OF FAILED CORRECT.
NO THAT'S A ARE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THINK THAT'S A GOOD.
IN THE THE ISSUE HAPPENED IS
THAT AFTER REDEVELOPMENT WAS
DISSOLVED.
A ANY PROPERTY THAT WAS A
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY WENT TO
REDEVELOPMENT SUCCESSOR AGENCY
AND HAS A DIFFERENT SET OF LAWS
THAT AND THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW
BEFORE WE CAN TRANSFER RELEASE
THAT PROPERTY.
IS JASON PROPERTIES ARE PART OF
THE HOUSE.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO CLEAR UP
THE THE THE LAW HERE SO THAT ALL
THE PROPERTIES ARE TREATED LIKE
HOUSING SUCCESSOR PROPERTIES AND
CAN BE SOLD TOGETHER. TO GET TO
THE PROP IT'S ESSENTIALLY
SOLVING A BUREAUCRACY OF BARREL
PROBLEM.
AND THERE'S NO AGREEMENT IN
PUTTING IT OUT A BIT.
UP THERE A I COULDN'T HAVE GOT
THE SACRAMENT HOUSING
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY STAFF TO
COME OUT HERE REGARDING A ANY
KIND OF BIT QUESTIONS.
BUT OUT THERE.
REGARDLESS OF ANY PROPERTY THEY
WILL BE THE NORMAL PUBLIC
PROCESS FOR A BIT REQUIREMENTS
SO I'LL ASK A YET SO INTO THE
FROM THE SECOND HOUSING
REBUILDING AGENTS ACTUALLY SHE'S
COMING UP THE PART PART OF THE
PROBLEM HAS BEEN IS THAT WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT YOU HAVE THIS
PIECE.
OF LAND AND SEVEN TET DEL LEVEL
SIX SEVENTHS OF ITS OWN BY ONE
PERSON AND ONE SET AND THE
PROMISEOF THE DEVELOPERS CAO
LIKE OKAY WELL WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH ALL THIS TITLE ABOVE
ABOUT SANDRA AND IT WENT.
SO PUTTING THIS TOGETHER I THINK
IT'S GOOD IT IT IT'S THIS PARCEL
THAT SOLVING THE PROBLEM
ACTUALLY HERS.
YES REMEMBER MAYBE CAN ASK THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE BID.
OKAY THAT ANSWERS MY QUESTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ACTIVISTS
WILL
.
BIZARRE AND IT'S NOW GETS
CLARIFY --
WHETHER I YOU'RE TAKING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT YES
YES I AM YES I DID SO.
THANK YOU SO BECAUSE THE TIMING
WE'RE GONNA DO THAT --
AT THAT NEXT COMMITTEE HEARING
HAS ITS NEXT STOP IN THE PROCESS.
AND DOES WE EMOTION.
THERE'S A NEW THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
THEIR SECOND.
OF SECOND THE BILL.
AND WILL MOVE TO A VOTE.
WHICH LIKE CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I THAT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ADWARE CURRY WALDRON
BLOOM.
I BLOOM AYE CABALLERO GABRIEL
GABRIEL I GRAYSON LACKEY
[inaudible]
RIVAS.
REAVIS I'VE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
BOATS AND THANK YOU ALL.
YOU KNOW GET THE HANG OF THE
SENATE FOR THIRTY SECONDS --
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO YOUR NEXT
YEAR OLD DOCTOR PAN THAT'S ITEM
ELEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN NO.
THREE THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH
YEAH S. P. THIRTEEN NO THREE
WILL REQUIRE A MEDICAL
EXAMINER'S OFFICE TO BE
ESTABLISHED IN LIEU OF THE
SHERIFF CORNERS.
AND COUNTIES A POT WITH
POPULATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR MORE.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF
THE LAST ACTION LAST THREE
STATES ARE TO MAINTAIN A SHARE
OF CORNER MODEL TO INVESTIGATE
SUSPICIOUS DEATHS.
IN THIS MODEL ELECTED STE
OFFICIAL THE SHERPAS CHARGE WITH
CA CONDUCTING AUTOPSIES AND
INVESTIGATE SUSPICIOUS THAT'S
INCLUDING THOSE INVOLVING A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
CURRENTLY THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES OPERATOR
CHEF CORNER MODEL WHEREBY THE
SHARE FROM ELECTED OFFICIALS
RESPONSIBLE IF PRINT THAT THE
GETTING SUSPICIOUS THAT'S WHY
LICENSE POSITION.
MUST CONDUCT THE AUTOPSY ITSELF
DETERMINATION THE MANNER OF
DEATH --
WHICH WHETHER IT'S A HOMICIDE OR
AN ACCIDENT REMAINS VESTED TO
SHARE THAT MEANS THAT
UNDERSHERIFF CORNER MODEL --
THIS THE HEADLONG FORSMAN
OFFICIAL WHO NAY THAT MAY NOT
USUALLY DOESN'T HAVE A MEDICAL
BACKGROUND COULD OVERRULE THE
FINDINGS OF A BOARD CERTIFIED
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST THE
PERTAINS TO THE MANNER OF DEATH
DETERMINATION.
S. B. THIRTY NO THREE IS IN
RESPONSE.
TO ALLEGATIONS OF IMPROPER
INFLUENCE OF THE MEDICAL
DETERMINATION POSITIONS
CONDUCTING AUTOPSIES IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY AND ANOTHER
COUNTIES.
OUT TO QUALIFY BASICALLY SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY TO QUALIFIED
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST RESIGNED
LATE TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALLEGING
THAT SHARE.
PRESSURED THEM INTO CHANGING THE
FINDINGS REPORTS THE THE VIGILS
INVOLVE AN OFFICER RELATED
DEATHS THIS IS ALSO ALLEGE THAT
CRITICAL INFORMATION WHO WAS
WITH HELP FOR THE PURPOSE OF
FRUSTRATING THEIR ABILITY TO
ACCURATELY DETERMINE THE TYPE.
MANNER OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT THE D. A.
IN SAN WHAT --
CAN COUNTY WROTE ANEDITORIAL
THE SACRAMENTO BEE WARY NOTED.
THAT THE ACCOUNT IS FORTY
SUPPORTED MOVING TO A MEDICAL
EXAMS AND WHICH THE COUNTY
ITSELF DECIDE BUT HE ALSO MADE
NOTE THAT THIS WAS NOT AN ISSUE
THAT WAS ISOLATED SACKETT TO SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY ALONE THIS IS A
BROADER.
PROBLEM WHERE YOU HAVE THE
FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS AS AN
EMPLOYEE ESSENTIALLY OF THE A
SHARE OF CORNER.
NOW ENSURING THAT AUTOPSIES ARE
DONE IN AN ETHICAL EQUITABLE
MANNER IS ESSENTIAL IN ASSURING
CONFIDENCE IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THE AUTOPSIES ARE OFTEN THE
BASIS FOR CRIMINAL CHARGES IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT THE PUBLIC
GAINES A NET THREE FACTORS
DETERMINE FAULT LIVER JUSTICE
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE JURY AND
SOMEONE SAYS HERE'S THE AUTOPSY
REPORTS.
THAT ARE LEADING TO THE TYPE OF
CONCLUSIONS YOU WANT TO KNOW
THAT THE FARM HAS BEEN POUND THE
SCALES I ON BEHALF OF THE
PROSECUTION OR OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
ADDITIONAL CLINICAL
DETERMINATIONS MADE BY POSITIONS
MUST BE FREE FROM UNDUE AND
INFLUENCE FROM ELECTED FROM
POLITICAL OFFICIALS S. B. THIRTY
NO THREE IS A VITAL BILL THAT
SAFEGUARDS OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
BY INSULATING THE PROFESSIONALS
WHO WERE SPECIFIED OBJECTIVE
FACT POSITION THE FORENSIC
PATHOLOGIST FROM UNDUE PRESSURE
INTRUSION FROM INDIVIDUALS WITH
NO MEDICAL TRAINING AND WHO MAY
HAVE OTHER --
AGENDAS TODAY HAVE WITH ME
DOCTOR LIVES THAT YOU WANT TO
THE PATHOLOGIST --
AT SAN JOAQUIN --
WITH YOU.
EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
STATION TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL EXPECT
WE ASK WHAT I'VE IT.
THANK YOU LET'S HEAR FROM YOUR
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLACE.
BUT IT OFFICE YOU KNOW MY NAME
IS DOCTOR BENNETT TELL MY LITTLE
LAST YEAR I RECEIVED THE HIGHEST
AWARD ANY PHYSICIAN CON BE
SAVING THE UNITED STATES.
THE DISTINGUISHED SERVICE AWARD
FROM TO AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
I COME BEFORE YOU TODAY BECAUSE
I LOVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I COME BEFORE YOU TO DEATH
THAT SCIENTIST ON THAT'S A
PHYSICIAN.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT I HAVE
THE PAPER HERE BEEN.
ACADEMIES OF SCIENCE RECOGNIZE
THIS SAME PROBLEM IN NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT AMID A
RECOMMENDATION THAT EDICAL
EXAMINER'S OFFICE IN ITSELF
PUBLIC IN TRUST.
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE ON DUH --
AND PUB [inaudible]
PUBLIC TRUST. EIGHT TIMES OF
ADVANCES IN MEDICAL CARE.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE IT'S THAT
MUCH OF ALL ACADEMICS OF SCIENCE
ON MOUNTED DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE.
PUBLISHED ANOTHER PAPER ARTICLE
ON A SYSTEM DOES NOT SOLVE
PUBLIC CONTRAST PUBLIC.
CONFIDENCE AND ADVANCEMENT OF
MEDICINE ACCESS SCIENCE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE AND OTHER
PEOPLE WAS PUBLISHED.
DODD MOST IT TO DO IN AMERICA
SHOULD HOBBY COHEN A SYSTEM
WHICH IS AYE BARRY AYE TO QUIT
AT SYSTEM DAHLE WAS BORROWED
FARM IN SHUNT.
ENGLAND.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE STARTED THE
STATE OF THAT INVESTIGATION AND
AMERICA I'M PUBLISHED A POSITION
PAPER.
THAT HAVE WE COUNTY ABOVE THE
POPULATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MUST AND SHOULD HAVE A
MEDICAL EXAMINER'S SYSTEM.
WHY DO WE DO THAT A PREVENTS ON
UNDERMINES THE ADVANCEMENT OF
MEDICAL SCIENCE?
I DISCOVERED CHRONIC TRAUMATIC
ENCEPHALOPATHY FROM MY LAPTOP
SEE I DID BECAUSE HOURS WALKING
THE MEDICAL EXAMINER SYSTEM.
I DISCOVERED HOW TO WEST NILE
VIRUS IN FACT THE HUMAN BRAIN
HOW WE COSTS A SENSE OF PUBLIC
PUPPY FROM A NOT TOPSY.
ALTHOUGH I MEAN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OFF PERFORMED WHICH
SUCH IN THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA IN A MEDICAL
EXAMINER SYSTEM.
STARTED A POT THOSE ON CAUSES
ALSO CITES OVER TWENTY YEARS.
IN A SYSTEM WHERE DOCTORS ARE IN
CHARGE WHAT I DID GIVE ELECT
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS.
THAT IS A DESKTOP CBO FORENSIC
PATHOLOGISTS IN THE UNITED
STATES TODAY BECAUSE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
POLICE OFFICERS CANNOT TRAIN.
THE STATE OF TEXAS WHICH HAS A
POPULATION OF TWENTY FIVE MEDIAN
HOUSE FIGHT TRAINING POSITIONS
FOR FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS.
THIS THAT PROBLEM SOLVING.
WHICH HAS A POPULATION OF SIX
MEDIAN.
HOUSE TO TRAINING POSITIONS FOR
FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS NOW LISTEN
TO THIS THIS STEP OF CALIFORNIA
WE PAY POPULATION OF TEXAS SEVEN
MEDIA.
OTHER WEEK TO TRAINING PROGRAMS
FOR FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST UNJUST
TO TRAINING PROGRAMS I SAN DIEGO
AND LOS ANGELES.
WHICH A MEDICAL EXAMINER'S.
IS SO THAT IT'S IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT WHEN I HEAR PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT MY NOW THAT CONCEPT THAT
THIS IS ABOUT ALL OF US.
ABOUT OUR CHILDREN INSTEAD OF
MEDICAL EXAMINER A DEATH
INVESTIGATION IN CALIFORNIA IS
WASHED DOWN WHAT IT IS IN THE
STATE OF MISSISSIPPI.
IN A STATE OF MISSISSIPPI DEVON
PLAY IMPLEMENTED THE MOMENT AND
SYSTEM THAT CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
TO BE GUEST ECONOMY.
AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
COST.
I MY QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE
TANGIBLE COST DUCK WILL BE MORE
EXPENSIVE DUMP PUBLIC TRUST
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE I'M PUBLIC
INTEREST [inaudible]
CHAVEZ SCIENTIST ANOTHER
PHYSICIAN THIS IS ABOUT MY
CHILDREN.
ABOUT YOUR CHILDREN SCIENCE IS
MOVING AT THE VERY FAST PACE A
QUESTION I ASK.
OTHER STATES ON CONSULTANT IN
AUGUST THAT EVERYBODY'S TALKING
ABOUT MUTATIONAL LA COPS WHO NOW.
THAT IS THE JET LOW MAKE
TECHNOLOGICAL KNOW HOW. TO
PERFORM GENETIC ANALYSIS ON A
HUMAN BEING RATHER THAN DO NOT
TOP.
SIX NOBODY'S TALKING ABOUT GOD
INDISPUTABLY.
IT'S A DOT WOES Y. WHEN I WAS A
PUSHED BY SENATOR UPON ON THE
SPIEL I DID MY RESEARCH I HAVE
SO MANY MORE.
RESEARCH I DID MY ME SUCH
CONFOUNDED AND DIE.
ADVICE IN LHASA APSO PHYSICIAN.
UP THINK IS THE BEST THING WE
COULD DO FOUGHT SHOULD ALLOW FOR
ALL OF US THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TO TALK
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION --
WERE PROUD SPONSOR OF
COSPONSORED [inaudible]
AMERICAN.
AND ASKED ME A WE FEEL THAT ARE
TIED TO DR AMALA BUT HERE FOR
THE TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SHRINK
AT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
EMILY CHILD ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND WHERE IN
SUPPORT --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
BOB BACK AROUND TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA'S IT PATHOLOGISTS IN
SUPPORT.
WE HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ONE LAST HOUR.
BUT DOUG SHIPMENT ON BEHALF OF
THE UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MISSILE PLOYS AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AS IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRAFFIC EVINGTON
THE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND THE URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS LEGISLATION.
COUNTIES CURRENTLY HAD THE
ABILITY TO CREATE AN OFFICE OF
THE MEDICAL EXAMINER.
BUT THE BUT THE GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION TWENTY FOUR ZERO TEN
PROVIDE THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO ABOLISH
THE OFFICE OF THE CORNER.
AND INSTEAD PROVIDE FOR THE
OFFICE OF THE MEDICAL EXAMINER.
COUNTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE CONSIDER WHAT
MODEL THURSDAY PEOPLE PASSED.
AT HAVE EXERCISED THAT AUTHORITY.
IT'S COUNTY THE CLUE SAN DIEGO
LOS ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO
VENTURA SANTA CLARA AND MOST
RECENTLY SAN JOAQUIN.
AND WELL I KNOW THAT THIS WITH
LARGER THAN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
AS IT IMPACTS SIX COUNTIES TOTAL.
I THINK THEY'RE WALKING IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE.
IT WITH AN ISSUE RAISED HAVE A
VERY SERIOUS ISSUE RAISED THAT
WORKING COUNTY HAD AUDIT DONE.
RECEIVE THE RESULTS OF THE AUDIT
AND THEN THE BOARD MOVED TO
CREATE A MEDICAL EXAMINER'S
OFFICE SO I THINK IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF LOCAL CONTROL.
AND THE LOCAL BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DETERMINING WHAT'S
BEST FOR THEIR COMMUNITY.
THE WHAT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES BELIEVES
THE SPELL I NECESSARILY CREATES
AN EXPENSIVE MANDATE.
AND REMOVES THE COUNTIES LOCAL
CONTROL TO DECIDE HOW TO BEST
ORGANIZE THEIR HI I'M KIM CHEN
I'M THE CORNER FOR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY --
BUT I'M NOT HERE TO REPRESENT.
ARE YOU STATE CORNERS
ASSOCIATION.
SO I ONLY HAVE THREE POINTS THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ON THE
FIRST IS THAT WE HAVE A
NATIONWIDE SHORTAGE OF FRANCE
APOLOGIST IT'S ABOUT.
MANY ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED IN THE
COUNTRY WE HAVE AROUND SIX
HUNDRED RIGHT NOW SO WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH PATHOLOGIST ACTUALLY
MEET THE DEMANDS.
FOR EVERY AGENCY --
TO MOVE TO MEDICAL EXAMINER'S
OFFICE ARE REALLY TOOK ALWAYS TO
RUN -- A
REGULAR OFFICE --
IF WE IF WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
DOCTORS WE RUN THE RISK OF NOT
HAVING --
REPORTS ISSUED IN A TIMELY
MANNER --
ONE OF THE INDUSTRY STANDARDS --
FOR REPORTS AUTOPSY REPORTS I'M
IS ABOUT NINETY DAYS --
I'M GLAD THE DOCTOR MOLLY
PRODUCT MISSISSIPPI BECAUSE
MISSISSIPPI'S ACTUALLY NOT A
VERY GOOD EXAMPLE --
OF HOW A GOOD.
HOW IT OFFICE SHOULD RUN AND
THEY RUN ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS TO A
YEAR BEHIND IN THE AUTOPSY
REPORTS THIS CREATES A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT I HAVE ENOUGH STAFF?
TO CHRIS ABOUT ISSUES WITH
GRIEVING FAMILIES THAT CAN'T GET
REPORTS AND IT CREATES ISSUES A
COURT A RIP IT CREATES ON ISSUES
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT ARE --
TRYING TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
TO FILE ON THE CASE SO
MISSISSIPPI'S FROM ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES THAT I WOULD NOT USE IS
A GOOD EXAMPLE FOR MOVEMENT TO A
MEDICAL EXAMINER SYSTEM.
AND THE OTHER THING THE THE NEXT
ONE IS AN INCREASED COST SO IT
JUST COSTS MORE TO RUN.
A MEDICAL EXAMINER SYSTEM
BECAUSE YOU NEED MORE DOCTORS
[inaudible]
AND THAT.
SAME MOCKING ACTUALLY LOOKED
INTO THIS WHEN THEY WERE TRYING
TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT TO MEET
TO MEDICAL EXAMINER SYSTEM.
AND THEY DETERMINED THAT IT
WOULD COST OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS MORE TO A JUST AND STAFF
COSTS.
AND TO CHANGE TO THIS MODEL.
AND THE FINAL THING IS ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS I'M.
KEEP AN AUTOPSY --
RESULTS OBJECTIVE ON THE MAKING
SURE THE MANNER IN THE CAUSE OF
DEATH ARE UNBIASED AND CHANGE
INTO THE SYSTEM REALLY ISN'T
GOING TO CHANGE THAT.
THE THE ISSUE IS WHO DO YOU HAVE
IN CHARGE AT YOUR AGENCY ARE
THEY UNBIASED.
A MEDICAL EXAMINER A CORNER A
SHARP CORNER THEY CAN ALL HAVE
BIASES AND CHANGE INTO THE
SYSTEM IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE AT
ALL.
SO UNFORTUNATELY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE CORNERS ASSOCIATION AS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
IN.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
REVENUE MANAGER MEMBERS I'M RYAN
CHAIRMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION WE'VE GOT
A BIT OF A DIFFERENT --
CONCERN FOR OUR OPPOSITION BASIS
I'M OUR MEMBERS WE REPRESENT
ABOUT --
MANY DOZEN --
CREEK DEPUTY CORNERS AND THEY'RE
GOING TO LOSE OUR JOBS AS A
RESULT OF THIS BECAUSE THEY WILL
NO LONGER BE ABLE TO SERVICE
PEACE OFFICERS UNDER A NON PEACE
OFFICER --
BOSS SO THAT'S ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST CONCERNS IS THAT AND
ALSO IF THIS BILL IS TRULY ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND AVOIDING
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST --
Y. DESERVE ONLY TARGET SIX
COUNTIES WHEN THERE'S DOZENS OF
COUNTIES THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN THIS BUT ARE NOT --
WERE CONCERNED THAT IT'S TRYING
TO FIX A PROBLEM THAT OCCURRED
WHEN COUNTY.
AND TIME WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT
PROBLEM IN OURS AND WE ONLY
MERGED OUR CORNER WITH OUR
SHERIFF --
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO.
SO ANYHOW I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND NO VOTE THANK YOU.
GOING FOR JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS CHORUS CELLS ALONE
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALSO
IF WITH RESPECT OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THEY WILL.
BE IMPLEMENTING THEIR ORDINANCE
IT'LL TAKE TWO YEARS WHICH IS A
LITTLE BIT TOO SHORT FOR THAT
ARE TOO LONG FOR THE PERIOD OF
TIME.
UNDER THE BILL NOW AND ALSO WE
ANTICIPATE STANISLAUS COUNTY TO
GUINNESS UNOPPOSED POSITION VERY
SHORTLY THINKING.
I THINK YOU'RE LEARNING OTHER IN
OPPOSITION.
SING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ARE ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND JUST
TO THE OPPOSITION FOR A MOMENT --
YOU'D MENTIONED THAT IT WOULD
COST IN ONE PARTICULAR CASE OF
IT WAS SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY.
AN ADDITIONAL ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SWITCH TO A MEDICAL
EXAMINER EXAMINER MODEL --
OUTSIDE OF THE MONEY ISSUE WOUND
WHY WOULDN'T A COUNTY WANT --
TO OR WHAT WOULD THE BENEFIT BE
NOT TO GO TO A MEDICAL EXAMINER
MODEL [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
THE BIT.
THE BENEFIT OF COURSE YES IS
COST -- WHEN
YOU START TALKING ABOUT --
EMPLOYING DOCTORS TO DO
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK AND THAT'S
QUITE EXPENSIVE WHEN THEY MAKE A
LOT MORE THAN ADMINISTRATOR --
I CAN'T SAY THAT ANY COUNTY
SHOULD DO ONE THING OR THE OTHER
I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT ONE SYSTEM
IS BETTER THAN THE OTHER I MIGHT
TELL YOU THAT.
WHAT I'LL TELL YOU THAT IT TELL
YOU IS IF THE SYSTEM IS GOOD?
AND THEY'RE UNBIASED AND THEY'RE
DOING THE JOB THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF THEY'RE CALLED CHAIR
OF CORNER MEDICAL EXAMINER OR
CORNER LIKE IBM.
IT IT JUST DEPENDS ON THE AGENCY.
NOT WHICH IS A PERFECT SEGUE
INTO MY NEXT QUESTION IF I MAY
CHAIR.
AND THAT IS --
TO GO TO THE PRESENTER.
AND ASKED --
THE QUESTION AND I BELIEVE IT'S
ALREADY BEEN STIPULATE OR AT
LEAST SET A COUPLE TIMES.
BUDGET --
THE COUNTIES ALREADY HAVE THE
OPTION TO CHOOSE WHETHER TO
STICK WITH THE CORNER --
MODEL OR MEDICAL EXAMINERS.
SO THAT THAT IS TRUE AND I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT --
PART OF THE REASON FOR THIS BILL
IS TO TRY TO ENSURE A MORE EQUAL
JUSTICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU OR
YOUR LOVED.
ONE ARE SOMEHOW A INCIDENT
HAPPENED AND AT THAT COUNTY --
MAYBE YOU'RE TRAVELING --
MAYBE THEY'LL LIVE ANOTHER
COUNTY.
AND YOU ARE IN A SITUATION WHERE
YOU -- AND
AND THE PORTION OF THE STATE
WHICH IS ACTUALLY FORD THERE'S A
SHARP CORNER NOW.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT WERE
POTENTIAL IS INVOLVED YOUR AND
THE ESSENTIALLY THE HEAD LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL THAT COUNTY
IS THE ONE WHO'S IN CHARGE OF
THE WARNER ARE A CHARGE OF THE
PART OF THE FORENSIC
PATHOLOGISTS PERFORMING THOSE
AUTOPSIES [inaudible]
SO -- THAT
CAN IMMEDIATELY RAISE QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT WHAT IS THE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ISSUES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAPPENED
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY --
ACTUALLY TOOK THE RESIGNATION OF
THE FORENSIC PATHOLOGY STYLISH
TO POINT OUT THAT I'M CURRENTLY
COUNTIES WHETHER YOU HAVE A
SHARP CORNER NOT ACCURATELY
HIGHER PRINCIPLE KNOWLEDGE
THROUGH THE WORK BECAUSE THAT'S
WHO HAS TO DO IT SO WE HAVE.
YOU READY HAVE PRINTS IT BUT
I'LL JUST WORKING FOR THE
COUNTIES ALRIGHT THAT THAT'S HIS
PERFORMING THE AUTOPSIES.
SO LET'S LET'S NOT CONFLATE AT
ISSUE OKAY SO YOU REALLY HAVE
THEM THEIR YURI PAYING FOR THEM.
AND THEN THE ISSUE IS IS THAT
WHEN THEY'RE PERFORMING THE EXAM --
IS SOMEONE SITTING THERE --
BASICALLY SAYING NO YOU CAN'T DO
THAT TEST BECAUSE WE WANT TO PAY
FOR IT ALRIGHT BUT THAT TEST IS
NECESSARY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED.
OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY SAY OH
WELL YOU KNOW YOU'RE REPORT WE A
CHEESE REPORT IN FACT THIS
ACTUALLY HAPPENED IN.
SAN WE CAN --
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY NOW SOMEBODY
WILL SAY WELL IT'S JUST TEN
WORKING COUNTY BUT IT'S NOT JUST
SAN JOAQUIN.
AND THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT THE
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST OUR
EMPLOYEES AND SINCE MOST OF THE
STATE ITS SHARE OF CORNERS.
AND THEY SAY SOMETHING I MEAN
THAT'S WHY THE THE US THAT THAT
THE DEFENSE PATHOLOGIST AND
SEVENTEEN WEBSITE BEFORE THEY
WERE ABLE TO SPEAK OUT.
BECAUSE I MEAN THAT'S WE HAVE TO
TELL PEOPLE TO DO IS RISK YOUR
CAREER RESIGN BEFORE YOU CAN SAY
SOMETHING YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
HEAR A WHOLE LOT OF THE SOME
PUBLIC.
UP BUT I'VE HEARD FROM PEOPLE
MORE PRIVATELY THEY SAID YEAH WE
HAVE PROBLEMS AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU CAN FIX THIS AND I THINK
THAT CERTAINLY.
I WANT TO BE SURE THAT WHEREVER
I TRAVEL YOU KNOW IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE.
ACROSS THE STATE AND NOT JUST IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE AND
THAT WHEN THE JURY HEARS A A. S.
AT AUTOPSY REPORT IT'S ONE
THAT'S NOT.
A POTENTIAL YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THAT DONE BY US IN THAT THERE'S
NOT A THERE'S NOT A CHANCE FOR
AYE CONFLICT INTEREST NOW I WILL
TELL YOU I THINK YOU'LL FOR MOST
PART.
MOST OF THE SHARE OF CORNERS ARE
PROBABLY HOPEFULLY.
I BELIEVE --
YELL ARE AT BEING HONEST AND
ABOUT ALL THE THE SITUATIONS
WHERE YOU HAVE.
A IT YOU KNOW IT'S AN INCIDENT
HAPPENS WITH THE DEATH.
AND PEOPLE ARE WAITING FOR THAT
AUTOPSY REPORT TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT REALLY HAPPENED.
AND SO WHEN.
A PERSON WHO'S ACTUALLY IN
CHARGE CAN CHANGE THE REPORT CAN
ACTUALLY LIMIT THE EXAMINATION.
IS THE CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER THAT'S THE UNFORTUNATELY
UNDERMINES CONFIDENCE EVEN IF
THEY DON'T DO ANYTHING RIGHT I
MEAN THAT'S A PUBLIC WELL GEE
THAT PERSON.
COULD HAVE DONE SOMETHING
[inaudible]
SO JUST REAL QUICK.
WITHOUT RESPECT A SENATOR AND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT THE
THIS IS SO PROBLEMATIC
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH OUR
COUNTIES THAT.
IN ESSENCE IT'S INCUMBENT ON US
TO TAKE THAT OPTION AWAY FROM
THE COUNTIES AND MANDATED ACROSS
THE STATE THAT THEY GO TO A
MEDICAL EXAMINER.
WELL CERTAINLY IT'S NOT JUST MY
OPINION --
AS NOTED IN THE PRESENTATION FOR
DOCTOR MOLLY --
NUMEROUS BODIES.
HAVE -- WHO
EXAMINED THIS ISSUE WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE ONE OF ONLY THREE STATES
LEFT THAT ACTUALLY HAVE A SHARE
OF CORNER SYSTEM SIR HAVE
BASICALLY SAID?
AT LEAST THE BEST PRACTICES THAT
MEDICAL EXAM SYSTEM AND THAT'S
WHY I YOU SEE PRETTY MUCH THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY.
MOVES TO A MEDICAL EXAMINER
SYSTEM AND WERE ONE OF ONLY
THREE STATES THAT STILL RETAINS
OF WHICH OF COURSE SYSTEM FOR A
BIG CHUNK OF OUR STATE I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
SENATOR I APPRECIATE.
SO WHOEVER HAVANA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE I'M I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THE SAME ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT BY MY
COLLEAGUE AND I GUESS THAT.
WILL IT REALLY BE THANK YOU FOR
THE CLARIFICATION THAT NO MATTER
WHETHER IT'S UNDER THE CORONER
OR THE THE MEDICAL EXAMINER THAT
IT'S A FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST IT'S
AGAIN I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
OF AYE I UNDERSTAND YOUR
ARGUMENT --
I'M I'M I'M CAN CONVINCE THAT
THERE'S SOME THERE IS A PROBLEM
BUT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHETHER THIS IS THE BEST
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM AT NIGHT.
BUT IT JUST IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
IF THE ARE.
THAT YOU MAY HAVE SOMEONE WHO'S
WHO'S.
WHO HOLDS YOUR PURSE STRING AND
SAYS MMHM WE KNOW WE'RE NOT
GONNA LET YOU DO THESE TESTS
THAT YOU NEED TO DO OR THAT CAN
INFLUENCE?
OR HAS ANY DURING COURT CHANGED
CHANGE IN THE REPORT ON IT
FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS.
HAVE A LICENSE.
AND THERE REQUIRED UNDER THEIR
LICENSE. TO ISSUE AN INDEPENDENT
DECISION BASED ON THEIR TRAINING
IS I WOULD ASSUME THAT THAT'S A
PART OF THE LICENSE BOMBS AND SO
IS A PART OF THE PROBLEM IS
IMAGINE OKAY YOUR DEFENSE
PATHOLOGIST YOU ACTION FULLER
I'M GONNA AT THE FRENCH
PATHOLOGIST ANSWERED.
OKAY IT IF I MAY HAVE LIED TO
YOU THE STATEMENT PUBLISHED IN
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT BUT NO I'M
I'M OKAY I'M AYE AYE EE AYE I
HEARD WHAT YOU SAID.
APARTMENT YOU SAID I'M JUST THAT
THE I GUESS THE THE THAT MY
ISSUE IS.
IT IS TO THE EXTENT THAT.
THERE MAY BE A SHERIFF.
WHO IS THE HEAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT?
THAT HAS THE ABILITY TO EITHER
CONTROL BUT THE BUDGET OR O PUT
PRESSURE ON YOU POLITICALLY.
ARM.
THAT'S A THAT'S THE WE CAN MAKE
THAT A VIOLATION OF THE LAW.
AND FOR WHICH A SHERIFF WHAT SO
CAN LOSE HIS POSITION AND SO I'M
I'M JUST TRY AND STRUGGLING WITH
THIS IDEA THAT WE GOTTA. FOR YOU
KNOW WE ALWAYS HAVE A BAD ACTOR
OUT HERE ALWAYS AND THEN WE
CHANGE EVERYTHING FOR THIS ONE
BAD ACTOR THAT ACTUALLY.
GETS RESOLVED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THE WAY IT WAS SUPPOSED --
TO AND SO I I'M JUST TRYING I'M
JUST I'M SO I THOUGHT I WAS A
LITTLE LATE AND IT'S THAT LET ME
JUST -- FOR
DESCRIBED ABOUT JUST ONE CASE
AND SANDWICH COUNTY.
OF IN FACT WE HAD THE ATTORNEY
OF ALL THAT CASE TESTIFY ON THE
SENATE SIDE --
A SICKLY THERE WAS A SITUATION
WHERE THE FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS
EXTENT OF A ACTUALLY DOES THAT
DID THE EXAM AND SUCH AND AND
SAID IT WAS ACTUALLY AND SO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF ALL DEATH.
AND IT WAS A HOMICIDE --
THE SHARP CORNER ACTUALLY UNDER
LAW HAS THE AUTHORITY TO DO THIS
CHANGE IT TO AN ACCIDENT.
AND THE REPORT SO THAT'S WHAT
WENT OUT IT'S AN ACCIDENT WAS A
HOMICIDE.
IT FINALLY THROUGH A THROUGH THE
LAWSUITS THAT WERE DONE --
THEY ACTUALLY THAT THE FINALLY
THAT SHERIFF CORNER NOW WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT YOUR QUARTERS
MAKE MOST OF THE CORNERS
ASSOCIATIONS ARE REALLY TALK BUT
THE SAME PEOPLE AS A CORNER
SENSATIONS THE SHERIFF'S --
THAT WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT THEY
FINALLY THROUGH THROUGH THE
LEGAL HAVE FINALLY CHANGE IT YOU
REALIZE IT'S TOO EMBARRASSING
AND CHANGED IT BACK TO HOMICIDE
WHICH IS WHAT THE FRANTIC
PATHOLOGIST PUT TO RETURN REPORT
WHAT THE OFFICIAL REPORT SHOWED.
WAS ACCIDENT.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT.
THE SHERIFF CORNER WHO HAD UNDER
LAW HAS IT THE WAY TO DO IS SAY
NO IT'S AN ACCIDENT --
AND WOOD AND SO THAT THAT
BECOMES A PROBLEM RIGHT --
WENT WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
CERTAINLY DID FIGURE OUT WHY WE
DON'T CHANGE THAT PART OF THE
LAW AYE DADDY I DIDN'T TRY TO
CHANGE THAT PART A LOT WAS
OPPOSED BY THE VERY.
PEOPLE WHO ARE POSING AS BILLS
WELL [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FELT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M.
SO WHAT I'M THINKING HERE TO
SHARE OF CORNER SYSTEM.
IF WE CHANGE IT AT THE STATE
LEVEL IT'S ONE SIZE FITS ALL BE
TAKEN AWAY MAJOR [inaudible]
LOCAL CONTROL.
FROM THE COUNTIES SO I'M I'M
STRUGGLING LIKE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WITH THAT.
BUT THE SYSTEM SEEMS TO BE
WORKING.
AGAINST THE BAD PLAYERS BECAUSE
NO MATTER WHICH METHOD YOU HAVE.
IF SOMEONE FEELS THEY'VE NOT
BEEN TREATED CORRECTLY IT'S
GOING TO A LAWSUIT IS GOING TO
BE JUDGED IN COURT.
ARMED WITH A OF JURY OF PEERS SO
IT SEEMS TO ME.
THAT LAWSUITS WILL BE THE FINAL
ARBITER FIGHTER OF EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENS ON THE REPORTS.
SO.
I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS --
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN THE
FUTURE SOME OTHER [inaudible]
SYSTEMATIC [inaudible]
CORRECTIONS. TO TRY TO STOP
EGREGIOUS REPORTS SO.
I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU.
PUMP AND THE COMMON I I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE RIGHT NOW IS THAT.
RIGHT NOT ME WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT THORIN.
WE NEED TO RESTORE TRUST.
AND THIS IS WHAT.
IN MY EYES THIS BILL DOES.
AND THAT'S WHAT IS I THINK THE
THE CAR COMMUNITIES ARE LOOKING
FOR IS THE RESTORING TRUST.
AND MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND I'M I APPRECIATE THIS IT'S
TOUGH TAKE ON OF A BILL LIKE
THIS BUT I THINK THAT WE'RE
HEADED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY --
WE DON'T WE DIDN'T MEAN TO THE
MOTION [inaudible]
THE SECOND.
YEAH ALBUM ON MAKE THE MOTION.
SEVERAL OF MOTION.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
UP.
I ADDED THAT.
I THINK THANK YOU SO MUCH --
FOR FOR FOR HEARING ME OUT I I
WOULD I WOULD JUST MAY BRIEFLY
RESPOND THAT.
IT ABOUT IN TERMS OF EXPECTING
PEOPLE TO HAVE TO SUE ALL THE
TIME OR TO GET JUSTICE --
I MEAN.
WHAT HAPPENS IF SOMEONE GOES TO
ARE A CRIMINAL?
THE JERRY I TO GO TOOK A
EXTERNAL TRIAL.
PEOPLE COUNT ON THE AUTOPSY IS
BEING OBJECTIVE --
FINDING --
TO TO TO ALLOW THE JUDGE AND THE
JURY TO MAKE JUSTICE THERE'S A
REASON WHY.
ARE.
THAT WE HAVE THAT IT IS ABOUT.
RESTORING JUST --
TRUSTS INNER TURMOIL JUSTICE
SYSTEM I EXPECT WE ASK WHEN I
BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY ADWARE CURRY HIGH
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM
[inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
REVERSE [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
THE BILL WILL NEED TWO VOTES WE
HAVE PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY MISSING
ALSO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
OKAY YOU NEXT WE HAVE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SP --
FIVE NINETEEN SENATOR BILL
.
SHORT AND SWEET.
WE CAN ONLY HOPE --
NOBLES.
BUT YOU NEVER KNOW --
THANK YOU --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
THIS IS --
S. B. OF FIVE ONE NINE AND THIS
BILL AMENDS THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ACT.
REQUIRED DISTRICT VACANCY ON THE
BOARD BE FILLED BY A PERSON WHO
LIVES WITHIN THE BOUNDARY OF THE
AFFECTED DISTRICT --
THEY CREATED THE DISTRICT
ELECTION SYSTEM SO YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE THAT.
ARE ELECTED LIVE IN THAT
DISTRICT MY AUNT MY INTENTIONS
AND TO ENSURE CONSTITUENTS ARE
PROPERLY REPRESENTED.
IT'S A BIPARTISAN BILL --
DISTRICT BILL LAST FOR ABOUT
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION YOU
WOULD --
HIGH ALERT.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHO'S SITTING
NEXT TO HER [inaudible]
SENATOR.
WELL I'M SURE MAKE YOUR MOM
TELLS ME UP BECAUSE HELLO MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BART BROOME REPRESENTING THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT.
ITEM WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS
COMMONSENSE CHANGE TO OUR
GOVERNING STATUTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE AREN'T ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE --
DRIVEN MOTION [inaudible]
PROMOTION.
THANK YOU SOME WE HAVE A SEGMENT --
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU BYE A HOUSE WHEN I
DON'T THINK.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD REFER TO THESE
DISTRICTS BEFORE ANYONE IS NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE VOTES OUT
THERE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THAT THIS IS A RECOMMENDED TO
PASS.
WELL THE ROLE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS ACT WHERE CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CABALLERO GABRIEL
GABRIEL I GRAYSON LACKEY REAVIS.
REAVIS I'VE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE [inaudible]
LEAVE.
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
IS THERE MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
OF THAT THERE IS.
THANK YOU IS THERE A SECOND ON
SEX CONSENT CALENDAR THANK YOU.
OF LET'S HAVE A VOTE ON CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ITEM NUMBER SIX
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY FOUR
BERRYHILL AGUIAR-CURRY.
WALDRON BLOOM AYE BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON LACKEY REVERSE.
REVERSE I'VE VOEPEL O..
VOEPEL AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE.
CALENDARS OUT FIVE ZERO AND WILL
MOVE ON TO ITEM EIGHT SP. ONE
ONE THREE ZERO SENATOR LEYVA.
FOR A TENTATIVE INDULGENCE HAD
JUST RAN UP THE STAIRS OF HYPE
HERE OUT OF BREATH I AM.
GOOD ALEX INSURANCE MANY TIMES
MYSELF PATRIOTIC.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT IF I
COULD THIS IS ABOUT MOM MOBILE
HOMES AS A CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE A MOBILE HOMES.
I WAS LIKE TO START ANY BILL
THAT I'M PRESENTING ABOUT MOBILE
HOMES AND LET MEMBERS KNOW HOW
MANY MOBILE HOME PARKS AND
SPACES.
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE IN THEIR
DISTRICT BECAUSE I THINK
SOMETIMES PEOPLE FORGET --
THAT THESE ARE REALLY THE LAST
BASTION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
MISTER BLOOM YOU HAVE THIRTEEN
MOBILE HOME PARKS AND SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX SPACES.
NOT THAT ANYBODY IS COUNTING NOT
THAT ANYONE'S COUNTING --
JUSTIN GABRIEL MISTER GABRIEL
YOU HAVE THIRTEEN ALSO WITH TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX SPACES IF
SOMEBODY DID YEAH YES SOMEONE
THERE'S THERE'S ACCOUNT MISTER
GRAYSON YOU HAVE.
FIFTY AND FIVE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THIS YOU
HAVE TWENTY EIGHT WITH THREE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR SPACES AND MISTER VOEPEL
YOU ARE THE WINNER.
WITH A TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT PARKS AND TWENTY THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO SPACE
AT THIS BILL HAS SOME SUBSTANCE
NOT JUST STATISTICS THAT RIGHT
IT DOES I JUST LIKE YOU KNOW I
THINK PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT MOBILE
HOME PARK SO BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE MISTER.
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN SB
ELEVEN THIRTY WOULD SIMPLY
REINSTATE MOBILE HOME OWNERS AS
ELVES WILL PARTICIPANTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA'S PROPERTY TAX
POSTPONEMENT PROGRAM.
THIS MEASURE WILL HELP TO KEEP
LOW INCOME DISABLED PERSONS AND
SENIORS IN THEIR HOMES AT A TIME
WHEN THEY NEED IT MOST. FOR MANY
YEARS AS PROGRAM HAS HELPED TO
ENSURE THAT LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS AND HOUSEHOLDS WHO
QUALIFY FOR THE PROGRAM DO NOT
LOSE THEIR HOME. TO A SET AT TAX
SALE DURING THE RECESSION THE
PROGRAM WAS ELIMINATED BUT WAS
LATER REESTABLISHED HOWEVER THE
REAUTHORIZING LEGISLATION DID
NOT INCLUDE MOBILE HOMES.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY WOULD HELP
SENIORS AND DISABLED PERSONS WHO
LIVE IN MOBILE HOMES BY ALLOWING
THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM WHEN THEY HAVE TROUBLE
PAYING THEIR PROPERTY TAXES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND HAVE A WITNESS IN SUPPLY.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CASEY
O'CONNOR ON THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR VICE CHAIR OF THE
BOARD LEGALIZATION FIONA MA.
AND SHE IS PROUD TO SPONSOR US
BE ELEVEN THIRTY AND THIS ISSUE
CAME TO OUR OFFICE WHEN WE GOT
PHONE CALLS FROM SOME.
ON DISABLED AND ELDERLY VETERANS
THAT ARE CONSTITUENTS OF VICE
CHAIRS AND THEY WANT TO KNOW WHY
THEY WERE ELIGIBLE BECAUSE THEY
CHECKED OFF EVERY BOX FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
EXCEPT THE FALLIBILITY
MANUFACTURED HOMES AND WE'RE
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
WERE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BASED
ON THE HOME THEY CHOSE TO LIVE
IN OR WHAT THEY COULD AFFORD TO
LIVE IN AT THE TIME.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY WELL WITH THEM AND
WE CAME UP WITH WHAT WE THOUGHT
WAS A VIABLE UNIQUE.
ARE ALTERNATIVE SITUATION TO
MAKE THIS A SUSTAINABLE PROGRAM
FOR NOT ONLY THE FOLKS CURRENTLY
IN THE PROGRAM BUT ALSO TO
INCORPORATE MANUFACTURED HOMES
BACK IN.
AND SORT OF THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
EVAN GOLDBERG STATE CONTROLLER
BETTY I JUST WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH OUR
OFFICE TO ENSURE THE PROGRAM
COULD BE ADMINISTERED AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU SIR --
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION LAST
CALL ARE THERE ANY --
OF QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IS THERE A MISTER VOEPEL.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT ON MANY
MANY PEOPLE LIVE A MOBILE HOME
PARKS BECAUSE THERE DISABLED
VETERANS THEIR SENIOR CITIZENS
THERE AND THERE'S MANY PEOPLE A
MOBILE HOME PARKS.
THAT OR ON LOW END SOCIAL
SECURITY YES THEY DIDN'T MAKE A
LOT OF MONEY WHEN THEY WERE
WORKING THEY ARE LIVING ON
ELEVEN HUNDRED A MONTH SOME.
EIGHT HUNDRED NINE HUNDRED A
MONTH AND THIS IS IT FOR THEM
THIS IS THEIR WORLD.
SO THIS BILL.
AUTHOR YES IS A GODSEND TOO MANY
OF THESE PEOPLE IN THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME THANK THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS MISTER SOME OF
THEM I'VE MET MANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE AND I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT
WOULD BE SO INSPIRED AND
PASSIONATE ABOUT MOBILE HOMES.
AND MANUFACTURED HOMES BUT I AM
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THAT ARE ARE THERE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
IS SEEING NONE HAS THERE BEEN A
MOTION YET [inaudible]
ENTERTAIN EMOTION.
OKAY REMOTE ASIAN ABOUT
ELECTIONS --
WHICH A TO CLOSE SENATOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY --
I REALLY APPRECIATE BRING THIS
FORWARD --
IT'S IN ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT AS
WELL [inaudible]
AND THE SO YOU RE EXPLAIN THE
FUTURE AMENDMENTS AS WELL I DID
NOT TO COME WHICH I CAN GO OVER
THOSE SO.
GEE ARE YOU WHAT YOU WANT TO
KNOW WOULD YOU MIND DOING SO SO
I MAKE SURE WE HAVE IT YES NOT
AT ALL SO THANK YOU TO YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE FOR HELPING US
WITHOUT THE DOUBLE REFERRAL AND
LOGISTICS OF THE BILL.
I'M WORKING ON FISCAL AMENDMENTS
THAT RECOMMENDED BY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY ASK EXECUTE THE
PROGRAM.
RATHER THAN CREATING A PARALLEL
BROUGHT FUND THE SUBMITTED
AMENDMENTS WILL ALLOW THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO USE THE
EXISTING FRAMEWORK OF TH
PROGRAM BY USING A MARGINAL
PERCENTAGE OF THE CURRENT
PROGRAM TO ASSIST MOBILE HOME
OWNERS.
SINCE IT IS DOUBLE REFERRED AND
THE SCHEDULE THE LEGISLATIVE
CALENDAR DID NOT PROVIDE US WITH
ADEQUATE TIME TO EXECUTE THE
AMENDMENTS SINCE COMMITTEE TOOK
POSSESSION OF THE BILL AFTER THE
AMENDMENT DEADLINE --
AYE AND STAFF FROM THE
CONTROLLER'S OFFICE CONTATO FOR
THAT IF IF NEED BE BUT WE ARE
FULLY PREPARED TO TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS AS WE MOVE FORWARD I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IS
CLARIFIED YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
NO I'M GOOD THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU.
FOR WHATEVER PHONE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AYE AGAR CURRY
I WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CUBBY AERO.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
REVERSE REAVIS I'VE VOEPEL AYE.
VOEPEL AYE.
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS OMITS HIS.
SENATOR LARA YOU KNOW AYE MOVE
ON TO THE SKINNER YOU.
SENATOR STONY READY TO GO.
FULL ONE YEAR WE COME ON UP.
JOIN THE FAMILY.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER --
NINE SP ONE TWO ZERO TWO MISTER
STARR SENATOR STONE WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND HONORABLE MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SP.
TWELVE OH TO IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THE MITIGATION FEE ACT
BECAME LAW UNDER AB SIXTEEN
HUNDRED IF FOLLOWS A NO LOAD IN
DOLAN APPELLATE DECISIONS
REQUIRING LOCAL AGENCIES
ESTABLISH A NEXUS.
THIS NEXUS IS A DIRECT AND
RELATABLE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
NEED FOR NEW INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SERVICE FACILITIES AND THE
PROPOSED GROWTH.
OF NEW DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
INCLUDING RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL
[inaudible]
AN INDUSTRIAL.
HOWEVER MANY LOCAL AGENCIES
WOULD LOCAL ORDINANCES ALLOWING
FOR THE COLLECTION OF MITIGATION
FEES FAIL. TO MEET THE ANNUAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT.
THE MITIGATION FEE ACTORS
CURRENTLY WITHOUT CORRECTIVE
MEASURES WHEN A LOCAL AGENCY
FAILS TO COMPLY WITH THIS
DIRECTIVES WHICH CAN FORCE LOCAL
DEVELOPMENTS TO COME TO A
COMPLETE HALT.
IF A LOCAL AGENCY FAILS TO
COMPLY WITH REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THREE STRAIGHT
YEARS SP TWELVE A TWO WOULD
TRIGGER AN INDEPENDENT AUDIT.
AND THE LOCAL AGENCY WOULD HAVE
TO PAY FOR THE COST OF THAT
AUDIT.
THIS WOULD HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT WHEN IT COMES TO LOCAL
AGENCIES CONTINUE TO COLLECT
MITIGATION FEES FOR NUMEROUS
YEARS IN A ROW.
BUT DO NOT COMPLETE THE
NECESSARY REPORTS THIS BILL PASS
OUT ASSESSMENT GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE IN OFF THE
SENATE FLOOR UNANIMOUSLY.
WITH ME TODAY IS GRETCHEN
GUTIERREZ WITH THE DESERT VALLEY
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
COACHELLA VALLEY THAT I
REPRESENT.
THINK WELCOME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AB MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY.
AS AS SENATOR STONE REFERENCED
MY NAME IS GRETCHEN GUTIERREZ
I'M THE CEO OF THE DESERT
VALLEY'S BUILDERS ASSOCIATION
LOCATED IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
WE PROVIDE SERVICE TO MEMBERSHIP
IN THE HOME RENEWABLE INDUSTRIES
AND A VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE BEING BUILT IN THE
COACHELLA IMPERIAL COUNTIES AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
THE REASON THAT WE ASKED SENATOR
KERRY IS THIS BILL FOREST'S IS
AS HE IS REFERENCED WE HAVE
SEVERAL AGENCIES NOT JUST IN OUR
AREA BUT UP AND DOWN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE FAILING
TO REPORT ON AN ANNUALIZED BASIS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH AGENCIES SUCH AS
OURSELVES THE GREAT PERSONALLY
ABLE TO GO OUT AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HANDLE THOSE REPORTING.
SO WE HAVE ASKED THE SENATOR
KERREY THE BILL FORCE TODAY IT
WOULD PROVIDE A CLOSURE TO THE
LOOPHOLE OF FAILURE TO REPORT IT
DOES GIVE THE AGENCIES THREE
YEARS IN WHICH TO GET INTO
COMPLIANCE.
MY ASSOCIATION IS PERFECTLY
WILLING AND IT HAS BEEN AMENABLE
TO AGENCIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE THEM GUIDANCE TO GET
THEM INTO COMPLIANCE OR TO HELP
THEM AS THEY HANDLE THEIR ANNUAL
REPORTING.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO TO
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT SAID THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE NOTED THAT THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY 3235% OF THE
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT ARE FAILING TO COMPLY FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THOSE AGENCIES
DO THE REPORTING SO THAT WE KNOW
THAT FUNDS THAT ARE.
COLLECTED UNDER THAT MITIGATION
FEE ACT ARE ACTUALLY REPORTED
AND THE EXPENDITURES ARE CORRECT
INACCURATE.
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WELCOME.
ASSISTANCE NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATIONS.
MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SAYING
NONE ARE GONNA WITNESSES
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
WELCOME.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
I'M ANTHONY TANNER HELL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WE HAD SOME
LINGERING CONCERNS AND AND I
WILL.
TOOK AN OPPOSING WAS MENDED BUT
FURTHER ANALYSIS IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND THE SPONSOR.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
REVISITING OPPOSITION AND
LOOKING FOR THE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ON
IMPLEMENTING THIS IS FAIRLY AS
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
I'M BY.
TOTALLY GET WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM.
I THINK PROBABLY THE THE
CHALLENGES FOR SOME OF THE RURAL
SMALLER COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
THESE.
THE DO NOT HAVE THE EXPERTISE
NOR THE STAFF TO DO THESE
REPORTS IN A TIMELY MANNER OR
MAYBE EVEN AT ALL.
RIGHT I THINK AS MUCH AS IT'S
HARD FOR THEM THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY OF
DOING IT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THIS WAS INTENDED TO DO YEARS
AGO
SO THANK YOU FOR BRING IN A
FOREIGN THANK YOU I'M SENATOR --
I WILL BE IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BOB
BILL TODAY FIGMENT OF HER.
OKAY WE NEED A MOTION TEN THE
SECOND.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION BY --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON AND THE
SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECT LAST NIGHT OF A THANK
YOU. TWO OF THEM.
SECRETARY CULTURAL THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY AYE GUERRA
CURRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM I COVER GYRO.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GRAYSON
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
REVERSE [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE.
BILLS ARE SEVEN ZERO GRADUATIONS
THANK YOU SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VERY MUCH.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR A FEW
AUTHORS IF THE SERGEANTS COULD
FOLLOW UP WITH THOSE FOR ME
PLEASE
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
BECAUSE YEAH [inaudible]
THE
SOON WE SENATOR SKINNER THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B. TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN ALLOWS HOUSE.
THAT THOSE BILLS TYPICALLY
[inaudible] FOR STUDENTS WHO
ARE ATTENDING ONE OF OUR TIME.
WESTERN ASSOCIATION ACCREDITED
COLLEGES WILL WORK QUICKLY NEED
COLLEGE [inaudible]
SYSTEM TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S [inaudible]
YES PRODUCE.
NOW YOU MIGHT THINK TWICE.
Y. LISTEN THAT ON THE RADIO
RECOUP THE DENSITY BONUS
CALIFORNIA'S DENSITY BONUS LOSS
ISN'T BASED ON UNITS.
AND IF YOU'RE BUILDING STUDENT
HOUSING.
MATCH IN THE DOOR OFTEN.
A SIGNATURE BATHROOM WHAT FLOOR --
IT -- AS
IT'S NOT.
IS EITHER.
MUCH MORE APPROPRIATE CALCULATED
BY BED SPORTBET GROUP.
SO THIS BILL FIXES THAT.
AND OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WELL HERE WE GO.
IT'S A BUSY DAY THE SENATOR I
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
SURE GO AHEAD [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
I SEE O. KNOWN.
SO THAT'S SUPPORT OF SORRY MADAM
CHAIR CANNELLA BURKE THE BEAR
COUNCIL PROUD TO BE A COSPONSOR
THIS BILL WHEN STRONG SUPPORT
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT I WAS A CLOSE CALL WOULD
HAVE APPEARED ANY AYE QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
REMEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS BUT QUE
EL WE NEED A MOTION.
OF EMOTION ME THE SECOND.
OR GOSH DARN I GUESS SOME TO
PLAYING LIKE --
MISTER WOOD YESTERDAY --
A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
THANK YOU ASKED FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS THIS IS A THIS
IS A GOOD BILL ME TO MAKE SURE
YOU MORE STUDENT HOUSING RIGHT
ON THE MONEY THANK YOU SENATOR --
SECRETARY KALRA.
MOTION IS DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WHERE CURRY
AYE AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO GABRIEL
GABRIEL I GRAYSON [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
REVERSE [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I BUILT.
BILLS UP FIVE ZERO THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
.
RELIVE THE CALL FOR S. BEFORE
ANYONE PAN.
THE CURRENT VOTES [inaudible]
THREE TO ONE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I WALDRON WALDRON
AYE CUB CUBBY ARROW.
GRAYSON.
LACKEY.
BILLS UP --
FIVE TO ONE WILL ALSO OF THE
CALL ON SP THIRTEEN OH THREE PAN
AS CURRENT [inaudible]
THREE TO ONE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CUBBY ARROW
[inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
LACKEY.
WE STILL NEED ONE VOTE SO WILL
HOLD ON THOSE FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BUT DID THE OUT ON THIS NOW FOR
HIS IN THE OUT ON THIS --
FOR CONSENT CALENDAR.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ADWARE CURRY I
WALDRON WALDRON AYE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO ANYWAY ONCE THE SINGER
ANYTHING FEEL FREE.
YEAH YEAH.
IT HAS BEEN A LONG AFTERNOON
.
ALRIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE
GONNA DO ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B.
NINE FORTY SIX GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR WELCOME AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE --
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WORK
EFFORT WHAT VENDORS SELLING FOOD
AND MERCHANDISE ON PUBLIC
SIDEWALKS.
OR IN A PUBLIC PARKS WE HAVE TO
START SEEING PEOPLE FOR WHO THEY
REALLY ARE THESE ARE WOMEN
SENIOR SINGLE PARENTS.
AND MICHAEL BUSINESS MICHAEL
BUSINESS OWNERS TAKING THE FIRST
STEP AT STARTING THEIR OWN
BUSINESS --
THEY DON'T COME LOOKING FOR A
HANDOUT AND THEY'RE NOT BANKING
ON OUR STREETS.
THAT THE FOOD AND GOODS THEY
SELL IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
FEEDING THEIR FAMILIES PAY THE
RENT OR BECOMING HOMELESS.
BUT TOO OFTEN A LOSS TREAT THEM
AS NEW AND SAYS.
AND EVEN CRIMINALS ARE LAW THAT
NOR THAT THEY ARE VICTIMS
THEMSELVES THEY OFTEN FACE
SHAKEDOWN FROM BUSINESSES AND
EXTORTION FROM LOCAL CRIMINAL
GANGS AND EVEN SOMETIMES LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THEY FACE HARASSMENT FROM LOCAL
OFFICIALS WHO SHOULD I BE THERE
TO PROTECT THEM --
THEY ARE ALREADY PAYING THE
PRICE OF THIS UNDERGROUND SYSTEM
THEY ARE WORKING PEOPLE WHO
WANNA BE PART OF THE FORMAL
ECONOMY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO WORK IN THE
SHADOWS BUT OUR LAWS GIVE THEM
NO OTHER CHOICE THEY WANT TO
PLAY BY THE RULES AND THEY WANT.
TO PAY THEIR THEIR FAIR SHARE.
AYE AND BUT MOSTLY IS THE
CALIFORNIA THE DAY AND MANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IMPOSE
OUTRIGHT PROHIBITIONS ON
SIDEWALKS AND ALSO WON'T VENDING.
WHILE OTHERS IMPOSE ERRONEOUS
RESTRICTIONS THAT SEVERELY
LIMITED AND REGULATE VENDORS TO
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
PERMITS OFTEN A BECOME
IMPOSSIBLE TO OBTAIN AND VENDING
WITHOUT A PERMIT HIS PROSECUTED
AS A CRIME THE CRIMINALIZATION
OF SIDEWALK FUNDING HAS
SIGNIFICANT AND DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES.
ESPECIALLY IN LOW INCOME AND
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
ADDITIONALLY MANY VENDORS REPORT
EQUIPMENT AND OTHER PROPERTY
HAVE BEEN CONFISCATED DURING
ENFORCEMENT ENCOUNTERS CREATED
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL STRESS.
A CRIMINAL PROSECUTION FOR
STREET ARE BENDING CAN ALSO
CARRY SEVERE CONSEQUENCES FOR
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT VENDORS A
CONVICTION MAY INCREASE
UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS.
PRIOR PRIORITY FOR REMOVAL UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY PRIOR ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM.
DOCUMENT VENDORS ARE HIGH PAYING
RISK FOR DEPORTATION EVEN IF
OTHER NOT EVEN ULTIMATELY
CONVICTED OR CHARGED INFRACTIONS
OFTEN TURN INTO MISDEMEANORS AND
VENDORS HAVE TO SERVE JAIL TIME.
PREVENTING THEM FROM PROVIDING
FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
WHICH KEEPS ALSO VENDORS --
FROM HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES UNDER THE NEW
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON A MINISTRY --
ON IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT UNDER
THIS ADMINISTRATION IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS ARE INSTRUCTED TO
PRIORITIZE THE DEPORTATION OF
THOSE WILL HAVE NEARLY CONVICTED
ACTS THAT CONSTITUTE A
CHARGEABLE CRIMINAL OFFENSE.
SO S. B. NINE FORTY SIX WILL
ALLOW LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO ADOPT
A SIDEWALK VENDING PROGRAM IN
ORDER TO ADEQUATELY ENFORCE.
ANY SITE WHAT VENDING VIOLATIONS.
PROVIDE THAT ANY VIOLATION OF
LOCAL SITE WHAT FUNDING ROLE
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO MINISTRY
THE PENALTY PROGRAM INSTEAD OF A
MISDEMEANOR OR INFECTION.
ESTABLISH A MINIMUM STAND STUFF
SAFETY STANDARDS TO GUIDE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES WHEN INITIATING A
SIDEWALK VENDING PROGRAM.
WE HAVE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS.
SPECIFICALLY THE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY LOCAL AUTHORITIES
DISCRETION TO IMPOSE IMPOSE
RESTRICTIONS ON PARK VENDING
REALLY THAT THE HEALTH SAFETY
AND WELFARE.
AS WELL AS ANY RESTRICTIONS THAT
THE FERRY TO SHOW THE PUBLIC'S
USE AND ENJOYMENT OF NATURAL
RESOURCES AND RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
WE AUTHORIZE ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO ADOPT
RESTRICTIONS NECESSARY TO
PREVENT A NONE TOO CONCENTRATION
OF COMMERCIAL ACTIVITY.
THAT UNREASONABLY INTERFERES
WITH THE SCENIC REALISTIC OF A
PARK.
PROTECT THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES
ABILITY TO IMPOSE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS UNIQUE
LOCAL SIDEWALK BENDING PRIMITIVE
PROGRAM RECORDING A VENDOR TO
OBTAIN OTHER STATE.
AND LOCAL BUSINESS LICENSES AND
REGULATIONS TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH DISABILITY ACCESS STANDARDS
FURTHERMORE AMENDMENTS ALLOW THE
LOCAL PERMITS. TO SUPERSEDE
SIDEWALK FENDING FOR THE
DURATION OF SUCH BORDER ACTIVITY
FOR EXAMPLE ALLOWING THE
PROHIBITION OF BENDING AND AREAS.
COVERED BY PHIL PHIL PERMITS
PARADES OR OUTDOOR CONCERTS.
AND WE ALSO CLARIFY THAT A LOCAL
AUTHORITY MAY PROHIBIT SIDEWALK
VENDORS IN ANY AREA IS LOCATED
WITHIN IMMEDIATE VICINITY OF A
CERTIFIED FARMER'S MARKET OR
SLIGHTLY.
S. B. MY FORTY SIX IS INTENDED
TO CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
BOTH BENEFICIAL TO LOCAL
ECONOMIES.
AND INCLUSIVE OF ALL SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ENTREPRENEURS
THIS BILL PROTECTVULNERABLE
FIND WHAT VENDORS AND CREATE A
NEW OPPORTUNITY FOR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND ECONOMIC
ABILITY WHILE STILL PRESERVING.
LOCAL CONTROL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU HOME UP.
FOR OKAY AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
YES I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
ARE MY NAME IS DOUG SMITH AND
I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH PUBLIC
COUNSEL WERE A PUBLIC INTEREST
IN CIVIL RIGHTS LAW FIRM IN LOS
ANGELES AND WE PROVIDE LEGAL
SUPPORT TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IMMIGRANTS AND LOW
INCOME ENTREPRENEURS INCLUDING
SIDEWALK VENDORS.
AND WE JOIN WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
IN THE CALIFORNIA STREET VENDOR
COALITION TO SUPPORT THE RIGHTS
OF LOW INCOME SIDEWALK VENDORS.
I IN MY WORK I HAVE SEEN FIRST
HAND HOW IMPORTANT VENDING IS
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
BENDING AS A WAY TO MAKE AN
HONEST LIVING FOR FOLKS HAVE
BEEN SHUT OUT OF OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE FORMAL
ECONOMY.
MANY VENDORS ARE SINGLE WOMEN
AND VENDING AFFORDS ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT AND THE ABILITY TO
EARN A LIVING WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR CHILDCARE AND
OTHER DEMANDS THAT OTHER
EMPLOYMENT MAY NOT. FOR MANY
RECENT IMMIGRANTS VENDING AS A
WAY TO GAIN AND ECONOMIC
FOOTHOLD AND START TOWARDS THAT
AMERICAN DREAM.
WE WORK WITH MANY VENDORS WHO
DREAM OF ONE DAY TURNING THE
PUSHCART INTO A FOOD TRUCK AND
THE NOT FOOD TRUCK INTO A
RESTAURANT.
BENDING IS ALSO AN INTEGRAL PART
OF THE FABRIC OF MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES BENDER CELL
CULTURALLY SIGNIFICANT FOOD AND
MERCHANDISE THAT'S NOT AVAILABLE
AND MAINSTREAM RETAIL.
VENDORS BY LOCAL THEY GENERATE
LOCAL TAX REVENUE AND CIRCULATE
MONEY AND NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE
IGNORED BY TRADITIONAL CAPITAL.
IN MANY FOOD AS OUR COMMUNITIES
FRUIT AND VEGETABLE VENDORS ARE
ACTUALLY THE ONLY SOURCE OF
HEALTHY FOOD RETAIL AVAILABLE.
AND VENDORS HELP SURROUNDING
RECKON ORDER BUSINESSES BY
BUYING THEIR SUPPLIES ACTIVATING
COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS AND
PROVIDING EXTRA EYES ON THE
STREET FOR SAFETY.
IN FACT A RECENT STUDY SHOWED
THE BRICK AND MORTAR BUSINESSES
ARE ACTUALLY MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE JOB GROWTH WHEN
STREET VENDORS WERE OPERATING
NEARBY. FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS
CALIFORNIANS LOVE AND CELEBRATE
SIDEWALK FUNDING UNFORTUNATELY
OUR LAWS DON'T ALWAYS REFLECT
THIS LOVE.
ACROSS THE STATE SIDE NOT
BENDING IS UNFAIRLY CRIMINALIZED
SOME JURISDICTIONS PREVENT
VENDING ENTIRELY WHILE OTHERS
IMPOSE RESTRICTIONS THAT AMOUNT
TO A DE FACTO PROHIBITION.
AND IF BEING FORCED INTO THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY AND DENIED
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY WERE NOT
BAD ENOUGH VENDORS ALSO FACE THE
THREAT OF CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
AND ALMOST EVERY JURISDICTION IN
THE STATE.
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED FOR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES THIS
CRIMINALIZATION IS ESPECIALLY
DEVASTATING CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
CAN RESULT IN ENORMOUS FINES AND
POTENTIAL JAIL TIME.
SIDEWALK VENDING ARRESTS HAVE
RESULTED IN DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS AND ONE RECENT CASE
A SINGLE MOTHER FOUR AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WAS
SEPARATED FROM HER CHILDREN AND
HELD IN A DETENTION FACILITY FOR
MONTHS.
AND STILL FACES DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS ALL STEMMING FROM ST
BENDING CITATION.
AND NOW UNDER AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE A VENDOR
MAY BE CONSIDERED A PRIORITY FOR
DEPORTATION EVEN WITHOUT BEING
CHARGED.
AS LONG AS BENDING CAN BE
CHARGED AS A CRIME WHICH IS THE
CASE IN MOST CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND COUNTIES BEEN IMMIGRANT
VENDORS ARE HEIGHTENED RISK.
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT S. B.
NINE FORTY SIX AS A NECESSARY
RESPONSE.
THE BILL DECRIMINALIZE THE
SIDEWALK VENDING WHILE STILL
ALLOWING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
CONTINUE TO ENFORCE THEIR LOCAL
VENDING RULES THEIR NON CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES.
THE BILL ALSO ENCOURAGES A LEGAL
FRAMEWORK FOR REGULATED SIDEWALK
MENDING THAT WILL OPEN UP HALF
THE LOW INCOME ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AND IMPROVING ECONOMIC MOBILITY
AND LOW INCOME IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
AS WELL AS IMPROVING FOOD SAFETY
BY ALIGNING VENDING WITH
EXISTING STATE FOOD SAFETY LAWS.
AND THE BILL EMPOWERS LOCAL
AUTHORITIES WITH THE FLEXIBILITY
TO ADOPT AND ENFORCE THEIR OWN
LOCALLY CRAFTED VENDING RULES
THAT ARE BASED ON PROTECTING THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE OF THE
PUBLIC.
AND ESTABLISH STANDARD THAT'S
FULLY WITHIN THE BROAD POLICE
POWER THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
ALREADY ENJOY.
SO AS A WHOLE S. B. NINE FORTY
SIX WILL HELP PROTECT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME WORKERS
AND IMMIGRANTS PROMOTE SAFE AND
PROPERLY REGULATED BENDING.
AND GREAT NEW OPPORTUNITY FOR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY ACROSS THE STATE FOR
THOSE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR GOTTA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY I'M CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
MY NAME IS CARLOS OR PISS AND I
AM A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN LOS
ANGELES.
I OWNER AND MANAGE A RESTAURANT
IN BOYLE HEIGHTS NEIGHBORHOOD
CALLED ONE SOLO SOLO.
I STARTED MY BUSINESS IN OCTOBER
[inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND TEN AND EVERY DAY I
AM PROUD AND HONORED TO BE PART
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS. TO BE A
SMALL BUSINESS. TO BE A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER.
I HAD TO OVERCOME MANY
CHALLENGES. TO DO WHAT I LOVE.
I HAD TO OVERCOME OBSTACLES SUCH
AS NOT.
QUALIFYING FOR A LOAN.
OR A LINE OF CREDIT.
WHILE EXPERIENCING MAJOR CYCLE
SHORTAGES.
IN CASH FLOW.
THIS I WILL VENDORS.
THAT WORK NEAR MY BUSINESS ARE
INTO PARTNERS JUST LIKE ME.
THEY'RE WORKING TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES AND PROVIDE FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY.
JUST LIKE ME.
THEY'RE PART OF THE BOOK BROADER
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
AND I BELIEVE.
WE SHOULD HAVE POLICIES THAT
UPLIFT ALL OF US.
NOT CONFRONT US AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
IT'S UNFAIR TO TREAT VENDORS
LIKE CRIMINALS.
WHEN THEY ARE WORKING TO MAKE AN
HONEST LIVING AND IMPROVING
THEIR COMMUNITY?
IF WE HAVE LAWS THAT THREAT
VENDORS WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT
I BELIEVE [inaudible]
MY NEIGHBORS [inaudible]
WILL BENEFIT.
SO WILL BE MY MISTER MY BUSINESS.
THE SIDEWALK VENDORS IN MY AREA
CONTRIBUTE TO A MORE LIVELY
PUBLIC AREA [inaudible]
I AND PROVIDE MORE AYE.
ON THE STREET EYES ON THE STREET
[inaudible]
WHICH HELPED.
ATTRACT CUSTOMERS TO ALL THE
BUSINESSES IN THE AREA INCLUDING
MINE.
WE ARE NOT COMPETITORS --
WE ARE PART OF A LOCAL ECONOMY
THAT REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR COMMUNITY.
SO I HOPE.
YOU WOULD APPROVE.
S. BENIGN. FORTY SIX TO HELP THE
VENDORS WHO ARE.
AN IMPORTANT PART.
OF THIS SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER ELDERS
I IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
CHRIS RESPONSIBLE ARE THE
COLLEGE REMAIN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
DIRECTLY OUR PRISON IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HAVE REPRESENTS
STREET VENDORS IN IMMIGRATION
PROCEEDINGS BECAUSE OF OUR
ARREST AND DEPORTATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EMILY CHILD ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND WHERE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT YOU KNOW THIS OVER WITH
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT MAKE
YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION HERE
SUPPORTER.
THANK YOU.
LUIS FRIDAY FROM CALIFORNIA BE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HOLD HOURS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD FARMING NETWORK IN
SACRAMENTO FOOD POLICY COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT.
I RUDY ESPINOZA WITH LEADERSHIP
FOR URBAN RENEWAL NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MCLEOD THE CULPRIT CESSATION OF
WHITE GRAPE GROWERS WE WERE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL --
WOULD LISTEN ANNOUNCES AN AS
APPROACH HOWEVER THE RECENT
MEMBERS ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
WHEN MICKEY CREDIT WE OFFICIALLY
OUT NO POSITION ON THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SIMILAR SENTIMENT JONATHAN CLAY
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA SWAT METERS
ASSOCIATION PREVIOUSLY OPPOSED
WITH THE RECENT AMENDMENTS ARE
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR'S
OFFICE WHERE NOW NEED FROM THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON RIGHTLY CALIFORNIA
CITIES --
UNFORTUNATE WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
AND I SUBMITTED POSITION ON THIS
BILL.
AND WE DO GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS THE RECENT
EVENTS ARE ARE QUITE HELPFUL THE
SENATOR STAFF AND SPONSORS HAVE
BEEN VERY OPEN TO HEARING NOW
ABOUT OUR CONCERNS.
A MEMBER HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN GET
THERE AND THEY'RE JUST REALLY TO
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT THAT WE
HAVE -- ONE
REALLY.
GETS TO HOW WE HOW WHEN AND
WHERE WE RESTRICT I'M STREET
VENDING OR JUST YOU KNOW ANY
SORT OF COMMERCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THIS BILL NARROWS IT ONLY TO
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE I'M WE
WOULD JUST LIKE TO MAINTAIN OUR
ABILITY TO REGULATE ANY ANYBODY
AS WE DO NOW SO WHEN I CAN TREAT
ANYBODY DIFFERENTLY THAN SOME
OTHER BUSINESS.
SETS ONE POINT AND THE OTHER
POINT I'M IS AROUND.
PORT CRIMINALIZATION OF IT
REALLY ANY SORT OF ACTIVITY IN
OUR COMMUNITY --
WE ARE FINE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES WE
THINK THAT THAT'S YOU KNOW
APPROPRIATE MAYBE FOR THE FIRST
FEW VIOLATIONS.
ON THE WE BELIEVE AT SOME POINT
IF SOMEBODY IS WILLFULLY
VIOLATING THE ORDINANCE THAT'S
IN PLACE THERE HAS TO BE
SOMETHING MORE THAN A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR FINE A REVOCATION
OF THAT PERMIT.
A BECAUSE IF THEY CONTINUE
VIOLATE THINK IT WILL JUST
CHARGE THEM WITH FIVE DOLLARS OF
PENALTIES THE NET AND IF THERE
ISN'T ANYTHING YOU KNOW MORE
AGGRESSIVE AT SOME POINT TAKE IT
MAYBE IT'S TEN VIOLATIONS OF ITS
FIFTEEN VIOLATIONS.
WE JUST THINK AT SOME POINT
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING MORE
THAN JUST ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY
AND WE WERE OVER THAT WE CAN GET
THERE OF THIS POINT WE HAVE
OPPOSE US IN A POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DOROTHY JOHNSON OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION --
AND REALLY DO APPRECIATE WE
THINK WE SAT DOWN BACK IN
DECEMBER TO FIRST HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS BILL SO
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY
ON THIS.
AND HONESTLY IF THIS BILL IS
SIMPLY ABOUT DECRIMINALIZATION I
DON'T THINK I'D BE HERE AT THIS
TABLE AT ALL.
ON BUT WE DO HAVE REMAINING
CONCERNS --
IN LIGHT OR DESPITE OF THE MOST
RECENTLY ADOPTED AMENDMENTS --
BUT EVEN THE FRAMEWORK WE HAVE
CONCERNS THAT WILL BE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF ENTREPRENEUR OLD
GAMING THE SYSTEM OF HAVING
THAT'S ALTERNATE PERMIT A
PROCESS FOR NON BRICK AND MORTAR
RETAILERS.
I'M AND ADDITIONALLY THERE'S
BEEN TERMS INTRODUCED INTO THIS
BILL THAT ARE NOT FAMILIAR WITH
AS LOCAL BUSINESS LICENSING
PRACTICES.
SUCH AS THE TEMPORARY CYBER
PERMIT AND USE OPPORTUNITY AND
THEN FINALLY WE QUESTIONS
SOMETIMES APPLICATION TO
COUNTIES MANY ROLE BUSINESSES
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE SIDEWALKS IN
FRONT OF THEIR THEIR AREA AND SO
WE DO WONDER.
CERTAIN --
PARTS OF OUR UNINCORPORATED
COUNTY SO FOR THESE REASONS
REMAIN OPPOSED THINK KILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
YES MY NAME IS ROLE RODRIGUEZ
JUNIOR AND I AM THE COORDINATOR
FOR AMERICA FIRST LATINOS.
AND I AM IN OPPOSITION.
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ROBIN BIDSTON WITH REMEMBRANCE
PROJECT IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS WE'VE BEEN
OF THE POST OF PRIME VERSION THE
BILL WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A CLOSE
LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS OF THE
AUTHORS PRESENTED TODAY --
AND RECESS OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
HOW DAVID JONES ABOUT THE CITIES
OF SAN MARCOS IN MARIETTA IN
OPPOSITION?
KURT BACHMANN ON BEHALF THE CITY
OF EL CAJON IN OPPOSITION.
HI DOT THE RODRIGUEZ FROM SAVE
OUR STATE MAY HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES NO I'M SORRY YOU JUST TO
NAME A ORGANIZATION [inaudible]
POST BUILDERS.
I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND
OPPOSED TO THE FACT THAT WE
CAN'T TAKE A FEW MINUTES.
OKAY HER THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YES ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL.
I'M.
MADAM CHAIR SOME QUICK COMMENTS --
THESE ARE NOT NECESSARILY IN
ORDER OF MY MAIN CONCERNS AND
I'M VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
BILL EVEN THOUGH I HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE SENATOR.
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO.
BUT FROM A SIXTEEN YEAR MAYOR'S
VIEW POINT WHA I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT.
SECTIONS IS LOCAL CONTROL IS A
BLOATED.
A CITY MUST HAVE JURISDICTION
[inaudible] TO REGULATE
[inaudible]
COMMERCE REGULATE NOT CONTROL
THE BUT REGULATED.
WE MUST BE ABLE TO CITE.
AND WRITE INFRACTION THERE MUST
BE CONSEQUENCES. TO ILLEGAL
VENDING.
THIS ALSO FOSTERS AN UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY --
MANY OF THE SIDEWALK VENDORS DO
NOT PAY OR COLLECT SALES TAX
[inaudible]
SO THAT.
HERTZ CITIES AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ECONOMICALLY.
ALSO FROM OF FOOD SAFETY
PREPARATION VIEWPOINT.
WE NEED TO REGULATE FOOD AND
PREPARATION STORAGE.
AND SALES FOR HEALTH REASONS
[inaudible]
SO.
WHERE DO THESE PEOPLE GO TO SELL
THE STUFF [inaudible]
FARMERS MARKETS.
IN MY CITY.
PUBLIC FESTIVALS IN THE PARTS.
ARTS WHAT MEETS ARE OPEN TO ALL
[inaudible]
AND MANY OF THIS CITY SUPPORTED --
EVENTS YOU DON'T HAVE PAID ANY
MONEY.
SET UP SHOP.
THAT'S EACH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
[inaudible]
CHOICE [inaudible]
I WOULD.
VERY MUCH WANT TO SEE AMENDMENTS
SIMPLY SAYING THAT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION [inaudible]
CAN HAVE.
AREAS TIMES FARMERS MARKETS
ACCEPT IRA [inaudible] FOR FREE.
FOR THOSE SIDEWALK VENDORS IN A
REGULATED AND ACCEPTABLE PLACE
FOR EVERYBODY [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
I'M NOT.
DEAD SET AGAINST THIS ALTHOUGH I
CAN'T SUPPORT IT RIGHT NOW BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AMENDMENTS.
THAT WOULD HELP OUT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SO THAT'S MY
COMMENTS.
WHERE DO LIKE RESPONDER THANK
YOU ALL HAVE OUR OUR EXPERT WHEN?
IF I COULD JUST RESPOND I AND I
THINK THOSE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT --
CONCERNS IN CONSIDERATION SO SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP
IN TERMS OF THAT.
THE NOTION OF OF PAYING OR
COLLECTING SALES TAX ON YOU KNOW
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE SPEND A
LOT OF TIME TALKING TO SIDEWALK
VENDORS THAT WE WORK WITH ABOUT
AND THE FOLKS THAT WE WORK WITH
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
ENTREPRENEURS THEY'RE THEY'RE
ASKING TO PAY THOSE TAXES THEY
WANT. TO FORMALIZE THEIR
BUSINESS SO RIGHT NOW IN A LOT
OF CITIES THERE ISN'T AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COME INTO THE
FORMAL ECONOMY.
THEY WANT TO BUILD THEIR
BUSINESS THEY WANT TO TURN THEIR
CAR INTO A TRUCK AND INTO A
RESTAURANT.
AND PART OF THAT IS IS JOINING
THE SO AS DRAFT THAT THE BILL
WOULD ALLOW CITIES ARTS YOU
REQUIRE BUSINESS LICENSES STATE
SELLERS PERMITS AND ALL THE
OTHER MECHANISMS THAT YOU WOULD
DO.
AYE TO INTEGRATE INTO THAT
ECONOMY AND BE PART OF THAT THE
TAXPAYING BASE AND SO IT IS
CLEARLY CONTEMPLATED AND PART OF
THAT AND I THINK BY.
BY OPENING THAT PATHWAY WE
CREATE A BETTER OPPORTUNITY FOR
MORE VENDORS TO COME INTO THE
SYSTEM AND START PAYING THOSE
TAXES IN THE WAY THAT THEY WANT
TO AND THAT WE WANT TO FROM A
REGULATORY STANDPOINT.
AND THEN THE OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT THAT YOU MADE
WAS AROUND FOOD SAFETY --
AND THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T DISENTANGLE
FROM THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
SIDEWALK VENDORS.
I'M A LOT OF SIDEWALK VENDORS DO
SELL FOOD.
AYE RIGHT NOW AGAIN BECAUSE OF
THESE BARRIERS THAT THEY HAVE TO
JOINING THE FORMAL ECONOMY.
ODD THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY
ALIGNED WITH EXISTING FOOD
SAFETY REGULATIONS STATE HAS
SOMETHING CALLED CALICO THE FOOD
RETAIL CODE WHICH HAS A A ROBUST
SET OF RESTRICTIONS AND
REGULATIONS ON FOOD SAFETY.
THAT APPLIES TO EVERYTHING FROM
RESTAURANTS ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
WHAT ARE CALLED MOBILE FOOD
FACILITIES WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
SIDEWALK VENDORS.
AND SO BY OPENING THE PATHWAY
FOR VENDORS TO FORMALIZE THEIR
BUSINESS AND TO AND TO TO PLAY
BY THE RULES THAT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION PUTS IN PLACE IT
WOULD BRING THEM IN LINE WITH.
THAT SYSTEM AND SO THE BILL ARE
EXPLICITLY CALLS OUT THE FOOD
RETAIL CODE.
AND SAYS THAT VENDORS THAT ARE
COMING INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
LOCAL DRASTIC REGULATIONS ARE
ALSO REQUIRED TO MEET ALL OF THE
REQUIREMENTS AND REGULATIONS
IMPOSED BY THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
RETAIL CODE AND SO IT.
IT'S A WAY TO GET THE VENDORS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY OPERATING IN
THE SHADOWS BRING THEM INTO A
SYSTEM WHERE THERE BETTER
ALIGNED WITH THOSE EXISTING
STANDARDS THAT WE ALL THAT WE
WANT ALL OF OUR OPERATORS THE
YEAH OTHER QUESTIONS.
SUMMER WALDRON IS YOUR QUESTION.
SO I AM.
NO I I TOTALLY SEWER YOU DOING
AND IT'S ALSO WHILE. FOR YOU
KNOW THE SALES TAX LOSE HEALTH
AND SAFETY PERMITS ALL THE
THINGS THAT ARE.
ARE IMPORTANT IN.
I JUST YOU KNOW I HAVE MY
CONCERN IS I HAVE ONE OF MY
CITIES IN HER POSITION SO I
WANNA AYE AND I SEE THAT IT
LOOKS LIKE THEY MIGHT BE AN
AVENUE TO GET. TO WHERE YOU WANT
TO GO SO.
IS THE CURRENT VERSION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AMENDMENTS.
THE JUNE ELEVENTH IS THAT THE
LAST TIME AMENDMENTS WILL PUT IN.
YES ASIDE OKAY YES [inaudible]
OKAY --
BECAUSE I SEE THAT THE REASONS
FOR DOING THE PROTECTIONS AND I
SEE.
HAVING A STATEWIDE WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT ALL THOSE THINGS A
POSITIVE --
AND SO WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WILL CONTINUE WORK I MEAN WE'VE
BEEN MEETING WITH THE SACK
PERMITS FOR A WHOLE YEAR HOW
PRACTICALLY AND EVERY CONCERN
THEY BROUGHT WE'VE.
TRIED TO ADDRESS WITH AMENDMENTS
THIS ISSUE OF NOT HAVING
SIDEWALKS AVAILABLE IS SOMETHING
THAT CO THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S A
REASONABLE.
A A CONVERSATION WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES OF THE JUST CAME IN
OPPOSITION THIS MONTH SO.
YOU KNOW THAT A LOT WE NEED SOME
KIND OF SAID THAT WITH THEM AND
AND FOR THE CLARIFY SOME OF THE
ISSUES.
THAT THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE
ADDRESSING TODAY AND JUST GIVE
US TIME TO GET THAT DONE BUT I
THINK WE'VE DEMONSTRATED
ESPECIALLY.
TO A TO SEE THOUGHT THAT WERE
WILLING TO JONES A AND THE FACT
IS YOU KNOW AT A CERTAIN POINT.
YOU CAN ADDRESSED ALL THE
CONCERNS AND THEY GET THEIR
STILL OPPOSED WHETHER IT'S AN
ISSUE OF JUST NOT WANTING
SIDEWALK VENDORS ARE NOT.
OUT THAT'S WHAT THE REALITY THAT
WERE LIVING AND AND SOME OF THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BUT WE WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE SACK AND WE WELCOME THE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS WITH NOW THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES.
ASSEMBLY ROOM BLOOM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
OF SENATOR I TO UC APPRECIATE
WHERE YOU'RE GOING WITH THE
SPELL I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
REVIEW THE AMENDMENTS SOUND IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
YOU'RE HEADED IN A GOOD
DIRECTION BY DO SHARE --
SOME OF THE A CONCERNS UP OF
OVER TIME PLACE AND MANNER --
AS DESCRIBED BY LEAGUE OF CITIES
AND THE AND AND THE COUNTIES --
THIS IS SET THIS IS FRANKLY NOT
A NEW ISSUE GOES TO SHARING A
PHOTOGRAPH OF OF MY
GRANDFATHER'S --
OF VAN THAT HE PEDALED DATA OF
VEGETABLES OUT OF WHEN HE WAS
YOUNG MAN --
AND SO THIS REALLY IS PART OF
THAT THE FABRIC OF AMERICA.
ON THE OTHER HAND --
THE LOOK AND FEEL AND CUSTOMS OF
OUR CITIES ARE ALSO I'M VERY
MUCH A PART OF THE FABRIC OF
FLORA.
A OF OUR COUNTRY AND WHERE WERE
AT A PLACE NOW WHERE.
I AM.
IN MANY PARTS OF MY DISTRICT AND
LIKE I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS
BECAUSE YOU'VE VISITED MY DOES
INTERNET BEFORE --
THERE IS A JUST A TREMENDOUS
COMPETITION FOR THE VERY VERY
LIMITED AMOUNT OF SPACE THAT'S
ON OUR SIDEWALKS.
I'M AND PEOPLE NEED TO BE ABLE --
TO PASSED BY AND AND AND THAT
WOULD LAW UNDER THE FIFTY
REQUIRE A COMPONENT OF OUR BILL
IF THE CITY TEAMS THAT.
AS NOT BEING SAFE THEN THEY CAN
GO AHEAD AND REGULATE IT UP
AGAIN WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
OTHER COMPONENTS WE FEEL ARE
IMPORTANT FOR FOR THE LEAGUE.
AGAIN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT
WORKS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
GIVE THE FLEXIBILITY AND THE
LOCAL SENATOR I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT --
UNLIKE MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE ON THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE HAVING SAT ON THE CITY
COUNCIL FOR MANY YEARS.
AND ATTEMPTED TO REGULATE STREET
PERFORMERS ON THE THIRD STREET
PROMENADE I'D AND FOOD TRUCKS AS
THEY WERE EMERGING PHENOMENON
AND NOW --
SCOOTERS --
I THOUGHT YOU KNOW THESE AREN'T
IT DOES NOT TRANSLATE TO LOCAL
POLICY VEY EASILY AND IT'S
FREQUENTLY A A MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED THAN WE MIGHT THINK
SO -- I'LL
JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT TIME WE
HAVE A FOR YOUR BILL TODAY AND
TO KEEP AN OPEN MIND TO AS IT --
APPROACH THE FLOOR THINKING.
SOME RIVER BASIN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I WILL JUST COMPARE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
EXPRESSED THEIR CONCERNS I SHARE
THOSE CONCERNS.
BUT DAD TODAY --
BASED ON TESTIMONY FROM
OPPOSITION ON YOUR COOPERATION
AND THEIR INTEREST IN CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH YOU.
I WILL SUPPORT TODAY --
TODAY YOUR BILL AND RESERVE
VOWED TO REEVALUATE IT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FLOOR IF IT REACHES
THAT FAR THANK YOU.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MEMBER REVERSED THIS IS OUR NEW
SOME ROOM BILL FOR CAROL.
THANK YOU UP NOW I JUST WANNA
THANK SENATOR LARA FOR FOR THIS
BILL -- YOU
KNOW I I SUPPORT YOUR BILL FOR A
LOTS OF MEMBERS IN MY DISTRICT
THIS IS A PATH TO
ENTREPRENEURSHIP --
THE MAJORITY OF MY DISTRICT ARE
IMMIGRANTS FROM MEXICO AND
CENTRAL AMERICA.
AND OFTENTIMES ON SOMETHING THAT
THEIR VENDING ON AS A SIDEWALK
VENDORS MAYBE SOMETHING UNIQUE
FROM THEIR TOWNER ON SOMETHING
THAT WE WANT --
AND AYE I FREQUENT SIDEWALK
VENDORS AND AND I WANT THEM TO
HAVE A PATH.
TOM TO TO BE LEGAL FOR THE FOR
THEIR BUSINESSES TO BE LEGAL I'M
SO THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT YOU'RE
DOING ESPECIALLY ON BEHALF OF
MEMBERS IN MY DISTRICT.
I'M I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE LEAK OF
CITIES ON YOUR OPPOSITION WAS
RELATED TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES YOU SAID.
ARE IS IT VIA THE AMOUNT THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT.
OR IS IT --
FOR IT TO JUST CONTINUE AS A A
VIOLATION FEAR ISN'T SO SORT OUR
CONCERN IS NOT SO MUCH WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ON PENALTY ITSELF.
AND WE THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY IS
ACTUALLY APPROPRIATE AND WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
SENATORS CONCERNS AND WHY HE
WANTS THE MEASURE PENALTIES WE
JUST THINK THAT AT AT SOME POINT
OF SOMEBODY.
IS A CHRONIC WILLFUL VIOLATORS
THAT THE NEEDS BE SOMETHING MORE
THAN ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY AND
YOU KNOW WHAT AT WHAT POINT DOES
THAT TRIGGERED THEM THAT'S
AGAINST THE BIG DEBATE.
IS THAT THE FOR THE FOR THE
VIOLATION IS THAT AFTER YOUR
PERMITS BEEN TAKEN FROM YOU YOU
CONTINUE TO VIOLATE YOU KNOW IF
WE WOULD THINK THAT AT THAT
POINT IT'S PROBABLY APPROPRIATE
TO HAVE SOMETHING MORE THAN A
MEASURE PENALTY.
BUT WE DO SUPPORT OF MAKING IT
NOT A MISDEMEANOR INFRACTION FOR
THE FIRST HOWEVER MANY OFFENSES
IS JUST FOR THOSE WILL FOR
CHRONIC VIOLATORS I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE SOMETHING MORE THAN
A THAN MISTER ITALY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE.
I AM I HAVE A QUICK COMMENT.
MACHINE BRING THIS BILL FOR
BECAUSE OF GIVING A PATH TO A
ENTREPRENEURSHIP THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
A I LOOK IN MY RURAL AREAS.
WE DON'T HAVE SIDEWALKS JUST TO
REMIND YOU.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
READ DO HAVE SIDEWALK VENDORS
FOR LACK OF AN UNKNOWN ANOTHER
WORD SO --
THAT'S WAS CONFUSED --
WHEN YOU SAID ABOUT WELL WHAT DO
YOU DO ABOUT THE FEAR HAVE
SIDEWALK WELL?
THERE'S A LOT OF FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES YOURSELVES ALONG THE
HIGHWAY.
IN MY REAL DISTRICTS SO I CAN
SEE WHERE THERE MIGHT BE SOME
CONFUSION ON THAT AS WELL --
BUT I THINK THAT --
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE FOR A PATH [inaudible]
AND IN RURAL AREAS IT'S
DIFFERENT I KNOW YOU HAVE MANY
MORE -- AND
A VARIETY OF PRODUCTS THAT ARE
SOLD THAT MAYBE NOT BE SOLD MY
AREA.
BUT I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
THINKING OF ABOUT OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY.
WE NEED A MOTION AND PROMOTION.
AND WE HAVE MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL.
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRIEVOUS.
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING. TO WORK WITH OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE EMOTION
IS DO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE COVEY AERO.
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I'D LACKEY REVERSE.
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL RESPECTFUL NO
[inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
BILLS OUT FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU
FROM WINNING TICKET
.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER --
THREE S. B. FIVE SIXTY ONE
ASSEMBLY EXCUSE ME SENATOR
GAINES AND SENATOR HILL WELCOME
.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR.
THANK YOU --
CHEER UP ACQUIRE CURRENT
APPRECIATE THIS IN MEMBERS --
PRESENTING TODAY SENATE BILL.
FIVE SIXTY ONE WHICH I WILL
ALLOW LANDOWNERS PROPERTY
INFORMALLY FLAKE. TO VOTE A I IN
DISTRICT ELECTIONS AND SERVICE
BOARD MEMBERS ON THE PHONE THE
FLIGHT COMMUNITY SERVICES
DISTRICT.
AND FONDLY FLAKE IS TUCKED AWAY
IN LAKE TAHOE BASIN.
AND MANY CABIN OWNERS AND
TOURISTS ENJOY THE BEAUTIFUL
SCENERY IN REMOTE NATURE.
OF FALL ONLY FLAKE IN THE WARMER
MONTHS.
HOWEVER IN THE WINTER MONTHS
ROAD ACCESS TO PHONE THE FLAKE
IS RESTRICTED.
FONG LEAFLIKE COMMUNITY SERVICES
DISTRICT PROVIDES FIRE
PROTECTION AS WELL AS
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES TO THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THE PUBLIC AT LARGE.
CURRENT LAW ONLY ALLOWS MEMBERS
TO SIT AND PARTICIPATE ON ABOARD
IF THERE A FULL TIME RESIDENT.
OF THE LOCATION UNFORTUNATELY
THE NATURE OF THE LOCATION MAKES
IT DIFFICULT FOR MEMBERS TO
QUALIFIED TO SERVE ON THE CSD
BOARD.
THIS BILL IS MEANT TO ADDRESS
THE UNIQUE NATURE FORMALLY FLAKE
CST RESIDENTS FACING ALLOW
LANDOWNERS. TO SERVE AS BOARD
MEMBERS OF THE CST IN ORDER TO
VOTE ON CST MATTERS THAT AFFECT
ONLY FLAKE.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT FROM THE
FONDLY COMMUNITY.
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FROM THE CSD
BOARD AND THE SUPPORT OF
SUPERVISORS TO NOVA CELL OF THE
OVERALL COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
MEMBERS THIS IS A LOCAL PROBLEM
WITHOUT LOCAL SOLUTION.
AND DIE I WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT I'M JOINED HERE TODAY
WITH MY JOINT AUTHOR SENATOR
HILL.
ALSO JOINING US IS MIKE --
MIKE CATHER CARD PRESIDENT OF
THE FALLEN LEAF BOARD AND DAVID
ANDERSON CABIN OWNER AT FALLEN
LEAF LAKE.
AND WE WILL ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AS RECOMMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS INTEND THAT SENATOR
GAINES FREELY EXPRESSED I THINK
THAT.
THE CHALLENGES OF THE COMMUNITY
AND FALLEN LEAF IN THE
SURROUNDING OPEN SPACE AND AS WE
KNOW IT'S THOSE HIKING TRAILS
ARE.
INTERNATIONALLY WELL KNOWN AND
OF THE KIND OF FAIR AND
PHENOMENAL TO MANY WHERE.
SHOULD BE IT UP.
IN ANY PROVIDES THE THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICT
REALLY PROVIDES A A SERVICE TO
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY AN
INVALUABLE PUBLIC SERVICE FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND THOSE VISITORS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD --
THE CHALLENGES WE KNOW IS.
TO MAYBE SOLVE THIS THIS
PARTICULAR PROBLEM --
THERE'S PRECEDENT FOR THIS
WEEK'S ON A B. THIRTY FIVE FORTY
EIGHT FROM NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
WHICH ALLOWED.
A FOR A SIMILAR SITUATION WITH
THE SIERRA LAKES WATER DISTRICT --
AND WE'VE LOOKED AT LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL OPINIONS IT SEEMS TO
AGREE WITH THIS.
OF THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE
BILL BUT WE LOOK FORWARD WITH
THE AMENDMENTS TO WORKING WITH.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO COME
TOGETHER AND I APPRECIATE IT THE
CHAIRS WOULD BE WILLING TO HELP
WITH THAT DURING THE INTERIM SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE A SOLUTION --
BECAUSE IT'S UP IT DOESN'T
REALLY.
BODE WELL FOR THE COMMUNITY AND
FOR THOSE TRAVELERS IT COME WITH
IT THERE ISN'T THAT THE ABILITY
TO PROVIDE A SAFE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM. TO TO VISIT AND ENJOY
THAT YOUR EARS PARTICIPATION AND
AND LEADERSHIP IN THAT WOULD BE
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL SO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
AND I'M MIGHT CATHCART ON THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE GALAXY
ES DE FOR FALLING LEAF LAKE WE
DO SUPPORT THE BILL.
UGH UNANIMOUSLY AND
WHOLEHEARTEDLY I ES DOES
VIRTUALLY EVERYBODY I KNOW OF I
KNOW NOBODY IN THE COMMUNITY WHO
DOESN'T DOES NOT SUPPORTED AND
ONE FOR A IN THIS FORM AND WHAT
IS WILLING.
TO PROBE THROUGH THE OF
AMENDMENTS AND HOPEFULLY.
IT WILL ENABLE US TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE AFFAIRS OF
THE CST THROUGH VOTING AND BY
DICK QUALIFYING TO BECOME
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD.
THE CSD IN ITS PRESENT FORMAT IS
AN INCREDIBLY VALUABLE RESOURCE
AT PROTECTING OVERSEEING
MANAGING AND ON PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR NOT ONLY THE THE
PRECIOUS VALUABLE ASSET WE HAVE
A FALLING LEAF LAKE AND ITS
ENVIRONS.
BUT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO USE IT
THAT ARE MANY INSTANCES MORE
THAN JUST THE CURRENT RESIDENTS.
SO IT'S BEEN ESTIMATED THAT90%
OF THE PEOPLE THE PEOPLE WHO
ENJOY SERVICES AND THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE CST THROUGH
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT THE STOE
THE MARINA.
ON AND THE COMMON AREA AND
ACCESS TO THE LAKE THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE PUBLIC PROPERTY THAT
THE CST OF OWNS AND OPERATES
AFTER THAT THEY HAD TRUST PUBLIC
LANDS TRANSACTION THAT'S AND
DESCRIBED IN THE MATERIALS YOU
HAVE -- 90%
OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE NON
RESIDENTS --
THE BENEFITS THAT THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES WHICH ARE
NOT ONLY THE FIRE SUPPRESSION OF
MAINTAINING AN ENCOURAGING AND
INSTRUCTING PEOPLE ON HELPING
THEM HOG.
WITH DEFENSIBLE SPACE OF THE
PROVIDING OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES WITH LESS QUALIFIED TO
DO PARAMEDIC SERVICES FOR THE
FIRST TIME THIS.
OF IN THE SUMMER I IN AN AREA
WHERE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
REACH THROUGH THE FIVE MILE ROAD
THAT'S DESCRIBED IN THE
MATERIALS.
YOU HAVE THAT CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT AT TIMES TO TREK TO A
TRAVEL ALONG VERTICALLY IN AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION.
OF AND THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
PROVIDES THROUGH SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES IT ENGAGES
AND AS A RESULT OF IT THE WAY
THAT THE FIRE CHIEF IN GENERAL
MANAGER.
HAS DEVELOPED A MODEL FOR HOW
CAN OPERATE A PROVIDE SERVICES
BEYOND FONG WE FEED STRIKE TEAM
ON OUR ACTIVITIES WHICH TO
PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
OF FORTUNATE REVENUE FOR THE
FIRED.
ACQUIRE A FIRE ENGINE IN A FIRE
VOTE AND IN ADDITION TO SOME
GRANT MONEY THAT HELP WITH ALL
THAT.
OF BUT THOSE STRIKING SERVICES
GO HAVE SERVED LAST YEAR'S FAR
NORTH AT THIRTY MILES SOUTH OF
THE OREGON BORDER AND TO VENTURA
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I'M SO IT'S A GREAT ORGANIZATION
IT'S A GREAT.
OF LAKE IT'S A GREAT POUND
SYSTEM THAT'S IN PLACE.
AND BASICALLY WE JUST WANT TO
FIGURE OUT OF A WAY TO GET MORE
PEOPLE FEELING COMFORTABLE
VOTING AND SERVING ON THE BOARD
THAT CURRENTLY DO AS YOU'VE SEEN
IN THE MATERIALS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
DAVID ANDI LIKE FOOD.
WELL I GUESS SO.
ACTUALLY NO I THAT MAY HAVE ONE
PULLED.
I WANT TO ADDRESS TWO ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED IN THE REPORT
WHICH IS BEFORE YOU.
THAT NUMBER ONE IS OF THEIR
PRESIDENTIAL VALUE OF WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR HERE AND WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR IS A VOTER SYSTEM
THAT COMBINES REGISTERED VOTERS.
WITH PROPERTY OWNERS AND I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT IS SENATOR
HELD AT THIS IS NOT NEW --
RUN WATER CODE SECTION THREE OF
SEVEN ZERO ZERO POINT SIX HAS
CONFIRMED AN IDENTICAL SYSTEM ON
THIS YEAR LIKES WATER DISTRICT.
ARE THAT PASSED THIS BODY IT
PASSED A AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR IT THEN PASSED
CHALLENGE IN COURT AS BEING
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
A AND IT HAS BEEN IN EFFECT
SINCE THEN AND I THINK IN
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL HAS RENDERED
A SIMILAR OPINION AND I BUT I
THINK THE IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
THAT BILL AND ITS HISTORY AS IT
WORKS.
I'VE SPOKEN WITH PLASTER COUNTY
WHICH ADMINISTERS IT AND YES IT
DOES WORK FOR THEM.
SECOND THE ISSUE OF FINANCES
WHICH WAS RAISED IN THE REPORT.
THE INFORMATION WHICH WAS
RECEIVED FROM LAST GOES DATED
AND FACT IS CURRENTLY OUT OF
DATE.
UNDER THE CURRENT BUSINESS PLAN
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT AND THE CST.
I'M ARE SELF SUPPORTING.
IT IS TRUE THAT WE'VE GAINED A
LOT OF MONEY RECENTLY TO TO THE
SERVICE OF STRIKE FORCES.
WE HAVE SENT AMOUNT I THINK
TWENTY ONE TIMES IN THE LAST
SEASON.
ARE WE ARE TOLD BY THE PEOPLE
WHO MONITOR THESE THINGS THAT
THIS YEAR IS LIKELY TO BE WORSE
THAN LAST YEAR.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT WILL
PROBABLY BE SENDING OUT MORE
STRIKE TEAMS.
HOWEVER ALTHOUGH THAT MONEY IS
CERTAINLY WELCOME AND IT
CERTAINLY LEFT US WITH A FAT
BANK ACCOUNT.
WHICH WE CAN SO THAT WE CAN DO
ANY EMPTY THAT SHARE IT IS NOT
NECESSARY FOR THE CST TO RUN.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY IS NUMBER ONE WITHOUT
THAT FIRE DEPARTMENT THE CABIN
OWNERS WILL BE UNABLE TO GET
FIRE INSURANCE.
THE COMMUNITY WILL HAVE TO DO
WHAT IS NECESSARY TO KEEP GOING.
AND THE COMMUNITY HAS
DEMONSTRATED ITS WILLINGNESS TO
VOTE FOR IT INCREASED A
ASSESSMENTS FOR THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH IT.
BUT THEY DO SO BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE ELSE
WILL BE REQUIRED TO DO THE SAME
THING.
IT PASSES TAX SORT SHARED
EQUALLY AMONGST THE COMMUNITY IF
THERE'S NO CST.
UNLIKELY THAT THE COMMUNITY BE
WILLING TO SIMPLY.
UP THERE ANY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT OTHER PEOPLE
MIGHT AT A SO AS CCAP GARTERS
POINTED OUT.
CST FORMS AND PERFORMS A LOT OF
FUNCTIONS THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE COMMUNITY.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO VERY IMPORTANT
OF THE PUBLIC AT LARGE.
WE'VE MANAGED TO DO IT OURSELVES
THIS IS I THINK SMALL GOVERNMENT
AT ITS BEST.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO IS KEEP
GOING AND WE CAN'T KEEP IT GOING?
WITHOUT DISPEL. FIVE IF I HAVE
TWENTY THREE AND A HALF SECONDS
LEFT MY TWO MINUTES OF MY
CLARIFY WHAT STRIKE TEAM IS IN
CASE.
ANYBODY INTERESTED IS INTERESTED
WHEN THERE IS A FIRE IN AN AREA
WITH THE LOCAL AREA CAN ASK FOR
HELP IN THE STRIKE TEAMS ARE
SUBMITTED PARTS SENT OUT.
BY A RECOGNIZE FIRE DEPARTMENTS
THEY HAVE TO HAVE AN APPARATUS A
TRAINED GROUP CAPABLE OF
OPERATING IT WITH THE SUFFICIENT
CARE OF EQUIPMENT NECESSARY TO
DO ALL OF THAT --
THE END WITH THAT'S DOES THE
THINGS THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT IT DOES GET REIMBURSED
ACCORDING TO CERTAIN FEE
SCHEDULES AND THAT'S THE INCOME
THAT.
EACH AREA THAT SENDS OUT A
STRIKE TEAM CAN ACQUIRE BY
OPERATING STRIKE TEAMS.
ON ANY GIVEN UNFORTUNATELY GIEN
CLIMATE CHANGE THERE PROBABLY A
THING OF THE PAST AND FUTURE.
THANK YOU THOSE TWENTY THREE
SECONDS SORRY TYPICALLY
[inaudible]
BUT ARE THERE ANY OTHER --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION INNER --
IN A FEW OF SUPPORTER OPPOSE OR
SUPPORT PLEASE.
I S. SAIMAA BILL SCHULTZ IN ON
THE ELECTED EL DORADO COUNTY.
RECORDER CLERK REGISTAR VOTERS
AND DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS DIRECTLY.
ORIGINALLY I WAS IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
WE HAVE WORKED TOGETHER THE
PEOPLE OF FOLLOWING THE FLAKE
ARE.
WONDERFUL THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO
GET ALONG I NOW SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
JAMES VAN SICKLE AND ALSO A
QUARTER OWNER AT THE CABINET.
IF ONLY.
JANET BENCIC CLAN AND OWNER OF
THE CABIN AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M CHRIS PLOTS BIRD ON A SIXTY
YEAR SUMMER RESIDENT OF FALLEN
LEAF.
AND I GREATLY APPRECIATE.
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY. TO
VOICE MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR FIVE
SIX ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M CHANGE STORY BOTS FORWARD
AND MY FAMILIES HAVE A CABINET
FORMALLY SINCE NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN AND MY HUSBAND'S FAMILY
SINCE THE FIFTIES AND I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THE SPELL THANK
YOU.
JOSH KIMBALL CAPTAIN PHONE THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ALBERT PELLERIN --
FIRE CAPTAIN THAT THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT PHONE LEAVE FROM NICE
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI CAROL SARGENT CABIN OWNER AND
BOY DO I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THINK YOU.
THEY'VE SERGEANT RELATED CAROL.
AND I SUPPORT [inaudible]
FIVE SIX ONE YOU.
ALAN SPANIER CABIN OWNER I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK.
TOM COLDER.
CABIN OWNER ON FOREST SERVICE
LAND AT FALLEN LEAF AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WORTH SUMMERS CABIN OWNER FALLEN
LEAF LAKE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SING OTHER ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THE MOTION.
ROSE SECOND GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH --
LET'S SEE WHERE HERE IN THE
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ANYTHING ELSE SORRY.
A I WANT TO JUST THINK COME COME
I REALLY APPRECIATE HIS WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS BECAUSE THIS
HAS A LOT OF PIECES TO IT THAT
SEEM.
SO SIMPLE ON THE SURFACE AND
THEN AS RECOUNTED WELL DOWN.
BECAME A LITTLE BIT MORE --
A DIFFICULT BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS I'M NOT ANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
SO I THINK YOU FIRST OF ALL FOR
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE IN THERE
WHEN FOR TAKING --
THE AMENDMENTS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I THINK USING THIS
STATE AUDITOR WILL BE
APPROPRIATE TO HELP US GET
THROUGH.
CAN I CAN FIND A WAY THROUGH IT
AND WE'LL HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH ALL THE PARTIES INVOLVED
WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT AS WELL.
AND I WILL BE VOTING FOR YOUR
BILL TODAY AS AMENDED.
OKAY -- WE
HAVE A MOTION ASSEMBLY QUESTION
YES YOU SURE SO THE BILL IS IS --
I I I I MAY HAVE SECONDED TO
QUICKLY ONE MAKE SURE WHAT I
SECONDED --
YOU'VE AGREED TO THE MET
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
OKAY GREAT [inaudible]
NEEDED ENOUGH.
OKAY WHICH I TO CLOSE.
EDWARD THAT URGENT AYE VOTE AND
THEN THANK YOU AND I JUST WANTED.
TO POINT OUT MY MY MY INTEREST
IN THIS LEGISLATION NOT
REPRESENTING FALLEN LEAF BUT AS
WE KNOW SO MANY PEOPLE FROM
AROUND THE STATE ENJOY A FALL
ONLY FLAKE IN THAT BEAUTIFUL
AREA.
IN THE STANFORD ALUMNI --
THE HITS INJURED STANFORD ALUMNI
LODGE IS IN THAT AREA I
REPRESENT STANFORD UNIVERSITY
AND ALL THOSE RESIDENTS OF NOW
THAT HAVE YOUTH COME OUT THE
TRUTH ABOUT IT OUT.
AND MY GOOD FRIEND.
WE DO NOT NEED A BIPARTISAN BILL
THAT IS THAT WE BOTH.
WE BOTH HAVE AN INTEREST IN
THEIR CONSTITUENTS ARE BOTH
ARTISTS BOTH CONSTITUENT WELL
THAT'S HOPEFULLY WE CAN MAKE
EVERYBODY HAPPY ABOUT HAVING
GREAT ALL SAID AND DONE OKAY
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
EMOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED IN
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING.
AG WE ARE CURRY AYE AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BLOOM I COVER EURO COVER YOUR
AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
LACKEY REAVIS [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I BILLS AT EIGHT ZERO
THANK YOU LOOK AT THE YOU KNOW
THE TALK I DON'T MEMBERS I THINK
THE OKAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER. FIVE SP NINE SIX
ONE MISTER SENATOR ALAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS IS YOU AND JUST
HOLD JUST FOR SAYING WE GET THIS
CREW OUT.
I WANNA MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE
ENTIRE STAGE YOUR SENATOR.
ALRIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD LET'S
SENATOR ALLEN BEGIN THANK YOU.
THE MEMBERS THIS IS S. B. NINE
SIXTY ONE THAT SECOND
NEIGHBORHOOD INFILL AND TRANSIT
IN THAT NEIGHBORHOOD INFILL
FINANCE.
AND TRANSIT IMPROVEMENTS ACT AYE
PROVIDES A VOLUNTARY TOOL FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE
COMMITTED. TO EXPEDITING TRANSIT
IMPROVEMENTS AND INCENTIVIZING
MIDDLE AND LOW INCOME HOUSING.
NEAR TRANSIT --
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT WE'VE ALL
BEEN WORKING HARD ON TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING --
CHALLENGES OF OUR STATE.
OF ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CAME FOR WITH THE IN A
HIGH PROFILE AND RATHER
AGGRESSIVE BILL.
ON RELATING TO THIS CHALLENGE
[inaudible]
THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME KIND
OF LOCAL CONTROL CHALLENGES AND
DISPLACEMENT CONCERNS ASSOCIATE
WITHOUT BILL BUT IT DOES TAKE A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN
TERMS OF ADDRESSING.
SOME OF OUR NEEDS OF THE COURTS
ATTENDED ARE IN DEVELOPMENT.
MY LEGS LEGISLATION ADDS. TO THE
LIST OF TAX INCREMENT FINANCING
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UNDER CALIFORNIA'S
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE.
FINANCING DISTRICT LAW THE I FD
LA.
I MOST NOTABLY BY PROVIDING FOR
AN OPTION FOR DISTRICT BOND
AGAINST.
I FUTURE SALES AND PROPERTY TAX
INCREMENTS WITH A VOTE OF I THE
COUNCIL.
AMENDMENTS WE'VE AGREED TO THAT
WHICH FOR PROCEDURAL REASONS
WOULD.
ARGUMENT OPTED AND ASSEMBLY
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE IF THIS
BILL PASSES TODAY WILL
INCORPORATE REQUIREMENTS THAT
DISTRICT HOLD A SERIES OF
HEARINGS ON ITS FINANCING PLAN.
AYE PROVIDING THE PUBLIC WITH
THE FORM OPPORTUNITY TO PROTEST
AND EVEN FORCE A DISTRICT WIDE
VOTE.
ON THE PLANET THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT OBJECTIONS.
OUR THIS FRAMEWORK MARIUS A
PROCESS THAT'S ALREADY AN
EXISTING STATUTE THAT GOVERNS
COMMITTEE REVITALIZATION
INVESTMENT AUTHORITIES THE
CREATES AND THE IDEA BEING THAT.
IF THERE IS SIGNIFICANT LOCAL
OPPOSITION COMMUNITY OPPOSITION
THERE'S THERE'S A THERE'S A
GRIEVANCE PROCEDURE THAT
SUBSTANTIVE.
NOT IN RETURN FOR PROVIDING A
POTENTIALLY EASIER PATH FOR
FINANCING THE BILL REQUIRES THAT
PRODUCE BEEN DISTRICTS TO VOTE
AT LEAST 40% OF TAX INCREMENT
FUNDS THEY COLLECT. TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO MAJOR TRANSIT TOP
THE BILL'S ALSO FOCUS ON
ENHANCING.
TRANSIT SYSTEMS AND SERVICE I
DIRECT INVESTMENT IN NEW TRANSIT
STATIONS WILL ALLOW.
ACCELERATION OR EXTENSION OF
APPROVED PROJECTS.
A DIRECT INVESTMENTS IN EXISTING
TRANSLATIONS WILL ALLOW
IMPORTANT STATION UPGRADES AND
FACILITATES DATA GOOD REPAIR ON
OLDER SYSTEMS SO UNDER THIS BILL
TAX AGREEMENTS CAN ALSO BE
EXPRESSLY USE DEFIANCE URBAN
FORESTRY.
LANDSCAPING GREETING
IMPROVEMENTS DETACHED OR
DECOUPLED PARKING IN LIEU OF
OUTSIDE PARKING FOR PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENTS.
FIRST AND LAST MILE ACCESS TO
TRANSIT FOR PEDESTRIANS AND
BICYCLISTS OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE
DISABILITIES.
OUR OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE IS
NEEDED FOR A REASON RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE WASTE RUNOFF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAPTURES
RAIN WATER URBAN RUNOFF.
I FINALLY I RECOGNIZE IT --
A FEW MONTHS BACK THIS VERY
COMMITTEE HOW.
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING THAT
EXAMINE VARIOUS TAX INCREMENT
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TOOLS
AVAILABLE UNDER STATE LAW WHICH
SCHOOL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
ADMITTEDLY BEEN SLOW TO ADOPT.
I AGREED THAT THE STATE WOULD
BENEFIT FROM A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY THIS IS
BEEN THE CASE IN S. B. NINE
SIXTY ONE INCLUDES A REQUIREMENT
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH COMPLETED
STUDY ON THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
TAX INCREMENT FINANCING TOOLS.
FOR INCREASING HOUSING
PRODUCTION INCLUDING A
COMPARISON OF THE RELATIVE
RELATIVE ADVANTAGES AND
DISADVANTAGES OF THE DIFFERENT
FRAMEWORKS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ADOPTED SINCE THE DAYS THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT.
BUT ULTIMATELY THIS JUST GIVES A
TOOL LOOKING GOVERNMENT'S
ENTIRELY PERMISSIVE.
AND IN THAT RESPECT IT IS IT IS
CENTERED IN THE IDEA INTRO.
WHICH I KNOW THE FOLKS AROUND
THIS TABLE CARED A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT AS DO I AS A FORMER
ELECTED OFFICIAL MYSELF AND SO --
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF DENNY'S AIN'T.
THE EXECUTOR ACTOR MOVE LA.
I WHICH IS ONE OF THE SPONSORS
OF A BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON YESTERDAY SAYING --
ALSO A FORMER COLLEAGUE COUNCIL
MEMBER ON THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA WITH ONE OF HER MEMBERS
OF SOME REMEMBER BLOOM --
MOVE LA AS AN ORGANIZATION WHICH
HELP TO A BILL THE COALITION TO
SPONSOR IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
MEASURES ARE IN MEASURES AT HOME
WHICH BOTH OF WHOM BOTH OF WHICH
WERE APPROVED BY VOTERS.
IN WHICH PROVIDE A VERY PROFOUND
INCREASE IN THE RESOURCE IS
VITAL TO DEVELOP TRANSIT.
I'M IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY A
REALLY I THINK A
TRANSFORMATIONAL MOMENT.
OF THEIR AND WE HAVE BEEN AND
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNISTIC COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AROUND THE TRANSIT
SYSTEM.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE
THAT IT REFLECTS THE NEEDS OF
LOW INCOME AND MODERATE INCOME
PEOPLE AS WELL WHO ARE THE
PRIMARY USERS OF THE TRANSIT
SYSTEM -- WE
ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
STRATEGIES WHICH I'M OFFERED.
TO NOT CREATE SIGNIFICANT
HOUSING AROUND THE SYSTEMS BUT
DON'T NOT.
A PROTECT OR OFFER UP WAYS IN
WHICH LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
PEOPLE COMMIT PART OF THAT.
FUTURE AS WELL SINCE THEY ARE
THE A BASE OF RIDERSHIP FOR THE
TRANSIT SYSTEM.
A WE THINK IT'SVERY IT'S VITAL
FOR ABOUT THE SYSTEM AND FRANKLY
FOR EQUINOX COMMUNITIES THAT WE
FOR PROVIDE A STRATEGY.
STARKLY TAX EGGMAN FINANCING HAS
BEEN A MAJOR PART OF THE TOOLS
THAT THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE USED TO PROVIDE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
NOT THAT I BELIEVE WILL AGAIN BE
THE CASE IN THE FUTURE.
BUT WE SHOULD MAKE EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS CONCENTRATED
TO THE EXTENT WHERE ABLE --
AROUND TRANSIT SYSTEMS THE STATE
HAS OF COURSE VMT REDUCTION
STRATEGIES GREENHOUSE GAS --
REDUCTION GOALS THAT THIS WOULD
HELP TO MEET AS WELL SO I THINK
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS A PROGRAM --
THAT SHARPENS THE FOCUSED AROUND
TRANSIT SYSTEM CREATES A PROCESS
WHEREBY GET LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MAKE A STRONGER COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND HAVE THEIR BY A MORE
REASONABLE PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD OR PREDICT WILL PROCESS
MEAN FOR IT TO SHORE --
THAT THERE'S A AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT OCCURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEARING
THIS THE THIS AFTERNOON I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR ALLEN FOR HIS
HOUSE AUTHORSHIP HERE.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON ANY AMENDMENTS ERNIE
SUGGESTED TO HAVE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
MEN IN COMMITTEE MEMBER SOME
LINDA ESCALANTE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
WERE IN SUPPORT.
EGGMAN CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE
JEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SPORT
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SING NONE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
NO HOCUS.
MAYBE NEVER SINCE SOMEONE GOT UP
THERE SENATOR.
ALL RIGHT THING THEN ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO COMMEND CENTER ALLEN THE
SPONSOR I THINK A LOT OF US HERE
AGREE THAT THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR STATE
IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST POPE
POLICY CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE
AND I THINK THIS IS A I SENSIBLE
APPROACH AND I THINK.
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO WORK
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO MEET THAT
CHALLENGE AND TO FOCUS ON
TRANSIT AS WELL SO.
MARIE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THAT I AND CAMANCHE.
OKAY ONLY EMOTION JUST TO
CLARIFY THE MOTION WILL BE DO
PASS IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE WILL
CROSS AMENDMENTS DUE TO THE
TIGHT TIMELINES WITH THE DOUBLE
REFERRAL.
FAIR ENOUGH SENATOR.
AND I AGREE TO MOVE THE BILL
OKAY OF THE MOTION.
AND A SECOND.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
CENTERS THIS THIS MADNESS ON
NUMBERS THIS SON OF BILL
RECEIVED A THIRTY EIGHT TWO ZERO
VOTE ON THE SENATE FLOOR --
WE REALLY DO THINK THAT IT IT AT
JUST THE SIGHT THE GOVERNANCE OF
FINANCE COMMITTEES ANNOUNCES
THEY SAID THE BILL INCENTIVIZE
GOOD DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS BY
PROVIDING.
A SOURCE OF FUNDS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
PROJECTS.
THAT MAKE TRANS OR DEVELOP AN
ATTRACTIVE TO DEVELOPERS IN
EXCHANGE FOR AN EASIER PATH THE
FINANCING IT DEMANDS MORE
SPENDING ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND OTHER FINANCING DISTRICTS
READING AN APPROPRIATE BALANCE.
BETWEEN PUBLIC BENEFITS IN AN
EXPEDITED PROCESS AND I I'D I
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS WORK
IN AND RESURFACE RIGHT ABOUT.
THANK YOU AND IN THE WORDS OF
THE SIMON REAVIS MORE TOOLS IN
THE TOOLBOX FOR THE LOCALS ALL
THE BETTER SEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
US THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO COVER EURO AYE
GABRIEL HE BRIEL I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY REVERSE
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING.
THE BILL SINCE.
BILLS OUT SIX ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THINK UP.
WE'RE WAITING FOR ANOTHER
PRESENTER WHO WE RIGHT WITH YOU
.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP ONE ZERO
EIGHT SEVEN SENATOR ROBB WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THIS BILL PERTAINS TO PACE AND
THE MEASURE BEFORE YOU PROPOSES
SOME.
IMPORTANT CLEAN UP PROVISIONS TO
LAST YEAR'S THE PACE BILL THAT
YOU MAY RECALL --
I'LL HIGHLIGHT THREE OF THE
BILL'S MOST IMPORTANT PROVISIONS
FOR YOU ALTHOUGH I'M SURE YOU'RE
FAMILIAR OPEN WITH THEM FIRST
BILL PROHIBITS HOME IMPROVEMENT
CONTRACTORS.
FROM COMMENCING HOME IMPROVEMENT
CONTRACTS AND MAKES HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACTS
UNENFORCEABLE.
IF A PROPERTY OWNER ENTERS INTO
A HOME IMPROVEMENT COUNTRY BASED
ON A REASONABLE BELIEF THAT THE
WORK WILL BE COVERED BY PACE AND
APPLIES.
FOR BUT IS NOT APPROVED FOR PACE
FINANCING IN THE AMOUNT
REQUESTED BY THE PROPERTY OWNER.
SECONDLY THE BILL INSURERS
TRANSPARENCY REGARDING PAY
SOLICITORS AND SILISTRA AGENTS
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT.
WHICH GIVES THE PUBLIC TOOLS ARE
OBVIOUSLY TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
FROM.
THOSE WHO HAVE NOT COMPLIED WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS.
AND THIRD THE BILL GIVES DB O.
THE ABILITY TO STEP IN AND TAKE
IMMEDIATE DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
IF TBL DB ó LEARNS THAT
THEY'VE SOLICITOR OR SOLICITOR
AGENT.
IS.
ARRANGING PAYS FINANCING
INTIMATE MANNER THAT IS HARMING.
HOMEOWNERS ME OF VARIOUS OF
SPORT FROM CONSUMER GROUPS
ETCETERA WITH REGARD TO THE BILL --
AND I WOULD DO RESPECTFULLY AT
THE APPROPRIATE POINT --
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I HAVE
SOME FOLKS HERE --
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR WELCOME THANK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NIKKI MORE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD AND FOLLOWING
THROUGH WITH THE COMMITMENT THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE IN THE ASSEMBLY
MADE.
TO CARE THE TRANSPARENCY
PROVISIONS THAT WERE PUT INTO
THE BILL AND VOTED ON IN THE
LAST DAY OF SESSION LAST YEAR.
UP BY REQUIRING THESE
DISCLOSURES WE THE PUBLIC HAS AN
ABILITY TO DETERMINE WHETHER
MISCONDUCT IS OCCURRING AND AND
PUTS PUBLIC ON NOTICE OF THAT SO
RESPECT THE URGENT AYE THAT.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS I'VE MY CHIN THAT'S KEY
WITH THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD.
THE CONTRACTORS BORDERS C. SLB
IS IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BECAUSE IT INCREASES
CONSUMER PROTECTION. FOR
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE SOLICITING TO
PAY SOLICITED INTO PACE
ASSESSMENT CONTRACTS.
MY PAYSLIP THERE'S A BASELESS OR
AGENTS THE PACE WITH THEIR THE
PACE WITH OUR AGENTS WILL BE
PRIMARILY SEE SMB LICENTIATE.
THAT IS I'M YOUR HOME
IMPROVEMENT SALES PEOPLE AND
YOUR LICENSE CONTRACTORS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE CSO BE IS
LIMITED IN ITS ABILITY TO
RESOLVE FOR HOMEOWNERS
COMPLAINTS THAT --
REALLY INVOLVED THE FINANCIAL
PRODUCT THAT THEY WERE SOLD IN
CONNECTION WITH THE HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACT ABSENT.
PROVABLE EVIDENCE OF FRAUD OR
MISREPRESENTATION THERE'S NOT A
LOT WE CAN DO FOR THE CONSUMER
AYE WE BELIEVE THAT BECAME A
SEVEN GOES A LONG WAY TO
INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY --
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND I PACE
PACE ASSESSMENT CONTRACTOR THERE
SO THE CONSUMERS ESPECIALLY WITH
THE REPORTING PROVISIONS THE
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS AND THE
UNDERWRITERS AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE THERE'S OTHERS --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS COURT IN
JOHNSON OF CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON ABERCROMBIE HAVE OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DIDN'T DECEIVE SOMEONE.
PAGE OF THE AFTER.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CASSIE
GILSON ON BEHALF OF RENOVATE
AMERICA I'M ONE OF THE LARGER
PIECE PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA
I'M ALL BE BRIEF BECAUSE WE'VE
DISCUSSED THIS ISSUEAT SEVERAL
TIMES TODAY AND I THINK THIS IS
THE FOURTH BILL IN THREE YEARS --
I WANT TO THANK VERY MUCH THE
SAME STAFF AND INDEED.
THE CHAIR AND HER STAFF AS WELL
FOR A TREMENDOUS WORK THAT
YOU'VE ALL DONE UP WORKING WITH
US TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF THESE
DETAILS OF THIS IS ONE OF THOSE.
PLACES WHERE DETAILS MATTER --
WE FIND OURSELVES IN A PUZZLED
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION BUT VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE AT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
AND APPRECIATE --
THE AUTHORS IN YOUR RECOGNITION
THAT PACE IS A CRITICAL PROGRAM
TO HELP US ADDRESS.
THE INEFFICIENCIES OF OUR
EXISTING BUILDING STOCK AND I'M
AND A HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO RESOLVE THIS GOING FORWARD
PINK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AB THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
I CHRIS ROGERS WITH BY GREEN
ENERGY FIND THAT ONE JUST ECHO
MY COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS AND AND
ESPECIALLY THE THANKS TO THE
SENATOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING SO DILIGENTLY WITH US.
AND ENSURING THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE PACE IS A
VIABLE OPTION IN CALIFORNIA A WE
ARE --
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION BUT AT THE
MOMENT REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
LATTIMER ON BEHALF OF RENEWED
FINANCIAL I WOULD CERTAINLY
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH COMMENTS
BY THE PREVIOUS.
TWO SYLVIA'S ALICIA BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY WE ALSO
CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION --
PIECE WE ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS
OF THE PEACE PROGRAM WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT WILL HELP US
MEET OUR IN EFFICIENCY GOALS IN
THE STATE AND SO WE HOPE TO WORK
FINALIZE.
THEM WORKING ON THIS LANGUAGE
THINKING.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE OF THEM
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YES.
A QUICK COMMENT ON I WAS MAYOR
OF SANTEE CALIFORNIA FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS AND WE HAD THE HERO PLAN
WHICH I UNDERSTAND IS VERY.
MUCH THE SAME AS PACE.
AND THERE WAS HORRIBLE ON
MARKETING PROBLEMS IN THE CITY
THE DIFFERENT MARKETERS WOULD
ABUSE -- ARE
ENDORSEMENT THEY WOULD SAY WE
ENDORSED PROGRAM ALL WE DID WAS
[inaudible]
APPROVED IT.
BUT THEY WOULD SAY ALL THIS IS A
CITY PROGRAM SO THERE WAS
HORRIBLE --
MISUSES OF THE HERO AND PACE
PROGRAM IN MY JURISDICTION.
AND I HOME.
WILL VOTE FOR THIS [inaudible]
GLADLY IT'S SOMETHING I'VE
WANTED TO SEE FOR MANY YEARS AND
SENATOR I ENCOURAGE YOU NOT TO
ACCEPT ANY AMENDMENTS.
STAND TALL BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
BE PROTECTING TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE SIR.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE NEED A MOTION.
FROM THE BILL OKAY AND SUCH --
OF AYE EVERY COUPLE THINGS FIRST
OF ALL I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR I
KNOW HOW HARD THIS IS BEEN
BECAUSE I'M WORKING WITH YOU TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE WE GET THE
SPACE PROGRAM ON BOARD.
I THINK WE BOTH AGREE THAT --
IT'S A GOOD PROGRAM THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
CLEANED UP AND I THINK WHERE
THEIR I WANNA THANK YOU --
FOR I MOVING FORWARD I'M VERY%
SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS TO CLEAN
UP TO STRENGTHENED PAPIS
OVERSIGHT ESPECIALLY IN THE
AREAS OF DUBIOUS ABILITY TO
ENFORCE EXISTING REQUIREMENTS --
THE PROTECTION OF PERSONAL
FINANCIAL INFORMATION
AVAILABILITY OF INFORMATION THAT
SHOULD BE READILY AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHAT ROTH AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING ON THIS
WITH ME AND I LOOK FOR TO US
WORKING TOGETHER TO GET THIS
FINAL THING TAKEN.
OVER THE FINISH LINE --
LET'S SEE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WILL MADAM CHAIR JUST LET
ME THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND MEMBERS YOUR CONSIDERATION.
AND ALSO YOUR PATIENCE I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR MY DELAY
[inaudible]
IT'S OKAY.
ALRIGHT --
THE TO REMOVE MOTION SECOND
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
BANKING AND FINANCE ACT WHERE
CURRY AYE AYE WHERE CURRY AYE
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO CABALLERO BY
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL BY [inaudible]
DOZENS.
BILLS OUT SIX ZERO THANK YOU ALL
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SENATOR WORKOUT.
IT'S IS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SP.
ONE THREE THREE THREE AND BEGIN
WHEN EVERY LIKE TO SIR.
THIS THING LAW REQUIRES ALL
CITIES TO THE BELT THE GENERAL
PLAN BUT DOES NOT REQUIRE A
CHARTER CITY TO BE CONSISTENT
WITH THE GENERAL PLAN.
RECENT APPELLATE COURT CASE
KENNEDY COMMISSION VERSUS THE
CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH
PERMITTED THE HUNTINGTON BEACH
ADOPTIVE SPECIFIC PLAN THAT
DIFFERS FROM ITS HOUSING ELEMENT.
THE NEW SPECIFIC PLANT
ELIMINATED SITES THAT WERE
INTENDED TO ACCOMMODATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SENATE BILL.
ONE THREE THREE THREE FIXES IT
AND CREATES A CONSISTENT SEE
REQUIREMENT TO APPLY FOR ALL THE
STE.
ALL THE STATE'S LOCAL PLANNING
AND ZONING ORDINANCES ARE
REQUIRED TO CHARTER CITIES AND
WITH THAT I HAVE.
A SHAUNA HARDEN IN THE WESTERN
CENTER OF LAW AND POVERTY AND
BRIAN AUGUSTA.
FROM HOUSING ADVOCATES SUPPORT
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURNED MEMBERS BY
NAME SASHA HERNDON AMOUNT
ADVOCATE WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY AND WE'RE
PROUD TO COSPONSOR THIS BILL --
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL
CITIES PLAY BY THE SAME RULES
WITH RESPECT TO PLANNING WHILE
PRESERVING THE ABILITY TO TAILOR
PLANTS TO LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
AS WE ALL KNOW LOCAL ZONING AND
DEVELOPMENT DECISIONS MADE BY
CITIES HAVE CONSEQUENCES THAT
REACH BEYOND CITY BOUNDARIES.
LOCAL DEVELOPMENT AFFECTS
COMPLEX REGIONAL SYSTEMS WITH
REGARDS TO TRANSPORTATION
HOUSING NATURAL SPEECH NATURAL
RESOURCES OPEN SPACE AND THE
LIKE -- AND
GIVEN OUR STATEWIDE HOUSING
SHORTAGE AND THE STATE'S
INTEREST IMPROPER REGIONAL
PLANNING.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT CITIES
FOLLOW UNIFORM PLANNING RULES.
THIS BILL WOULD ELIMINATE A TWO
TIERED SYSTEM WHERE ALL CITIES
HAVE.
TO ADOPT HOUSING OR ADOPT
GENERAL PLANTS WITH SPECIFIED
ELEMENTS BUT ONLY SOME CITIES
HAVE TO FOLLOW THEM --
AND WE CAN'T ALLOW SOME
JURISDICTIONS TO PASS ON THEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO OTHERS AND SO --
WITH THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY OR
CAN I THANK YOU.
WELCOME MY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBER TRYING TO GUEST ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
WITH EVERYTHING THAT --
WE DID LAST YEAR --
ON HOUSING WHICH MANY OF YOU
HELPED TO LEAD ON IT WOULD BE A
NOVELIST THAT WE HE WOULD COULD
[inaudible]
VOID COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE VERY
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE CENTER
SO CRITICAL TO MEETING THE
HOUSING NEEDS OF PEOPLE AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS THAT WE THINK THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE.
BILL TO ACHIEVE THAT OF
CONSISTENCY AND WE WOULD URGE
AND ABOUT.
I THINK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
A MY NAME IS LOUIS MONTANA WITH
CALIFORNIA WE JUST WANTED BACK
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SINGING AND ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO.
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND THE
THE ARGUMENT IN OPPOSITION AT
ALL AND I USUALLY LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER
WHY SOMEBODY WOULD OPPOSE
[inaudible]
FOUND SOMETHING.
SO IT IT.
AND I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE AWKWARD
TO TRY TO EXPLAIN WHAT THIS
OPPOSITION SAID ON SOMETHING
THAT YOU.
BUT IT IT SAM.
YEAH SOMEBODY ELSE'S OPPOSITION
IF YOU CAN JUST SAID THE CRAZY I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY MEAN BUT I
CHOSE [inaudible]
FINANCIAL [inaudible]
THE THEY WOULD.
I'M THAT IT WOULD LIMIT NO
HOUSING PROJECTS.
I'M HONESTLY NOT SURE I CAN
EXPLAIN THAT OKAY OPPOSITION --
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL EXEMPTS
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ENTERED INTO TO
ATTEMPTED TO AVOID DISRUPTING
THOSE -- AND
ANY DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENTS THAT
WOULD BE SIGNED GOING FORWARD
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
RULES THAT APPLY TO ALL
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENTS AND
GENERAL OF CITIES [inaudible]
GOOD ANSWER.
OKAY ISSUES ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE.
WE NEED A MOTION.
YOUR MOTION AND THE SECOND --
LET'S SEE WHICH I TO CLOSE. OH
EMBER WITH URGENT AYE VOTE.
THINGS COULD YOU OKAY A LET'S
SEE -- EVEN
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I THINK IT SHOULD BE
EVERYBODY HAS THE SAME RULES TO
FOLLOW BY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND US SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ACT WHERE CURRY AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CUBBY HERO CABALLERO I
KEY BRAILLE.
GRAYSON [inaudible]
LACKEY.
RIVAS VOEPEL NO VOEPEL NO.
THANK YOU I HAVE [inaudible]
IF YOU.
PROPOSAL CLEAN UP HERE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THEY NEED.
JUST TO CLARIFY THE VOTE ON
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE IS. THREE
TO TWO SO WELL WAY FOR THE REST
OF PEOPLE TO COME BACK
.
I WILL IF I CALL ON THIRTEEN OF
THREE ON PAN.
THERE WERE SOME OF PLACE.
THAT'S A HIGH PRIORITY
[inaudible]
A LOT [inaudible]
YEAH
FOR ADAMS ITEM ONE AND
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY WHEN.
CURRENT VOTE IS.
FIVE TWO ONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT CABALLERO
[inaudible]
CABALLERO AYE [inaudible]
I THINK [inaudible]
THE BILL.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETEEN BELL.
MOTION IS TO PASS CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE TWO ZERO WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE CABALLERO COVER EURO
I GRAYSON AND LACKEY.
ITEM NUMBER FOR SENATE BILL NINE
FORTY SIX LARA.
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE TWO ONE AND
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CUMPLIR I IS.
AND WE CAN REVISIT QUE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SENATE BILL NINE
SIXTY ONE ALLEN --
TO BE REFERRED TO THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIXTY ZERO
REAVIS [inaudible]
REAVIS I CONSENT CALENDAR SENATE
BILL TEN EIGHTY FOUR CUBBY AERO.
COVER EUROPE I ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AND SENATE BILL TONY SEVEN ROTH.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE BANKING
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTERS [inaudible]
SIXTY ZERO REAVIS [inaudible]
REAVIS I ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
LEYVA DO PASSED TO REVEREND TAX.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO
CABALLERO.
CUMPLIR I ITEM NUMBER NINE
SANDEL TROUBLE TO STONE.
MOTION IS TO PASS CURRENT VOTE
IS SEVEN ZERO CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SENATE BILL
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN SKINNER
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE ZERO
CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE [inaudible]
REAVIS [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE [inaudible]
AND THIS.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE WHITE
HOUSE GAVE MOTION AS DO PASSED A
HOUSING.
CURRENT VOTE.
ACTUALLY THIS.
ONE SCARES ME THIS IS UNCALLED
OKAY
.
WELL IF THE CALL ON THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO TWO GABRIEL
[inaudible]
GABRIEL I RIVAS [inaudible]
REAVIS I BILLS.
THE CLUB
FIVE TO TWO BUT THE
CALL ON THIRTEEN A THREE CURRENT
VOTERS FOR TO TO COVER THE ARROW
[inaudible]
CABALLERO AYE.
BILLS UP FIVE YOU
TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS ADJOURNED